foreign
[Music]
thank you
open to anyone
all around the world there's no way the
chess.com Global Championship offers the
dream of playing against the best we are
in for a wild ride and hey have we
mentioned there's also a million dollars
at stake the total pot is a million
dollars know that it's not a typo the
prizes are unbelievably generous The cgc
Knockout phase has hit crunch time
we began with thousands of players now
only a handful remains this is the most
lethal way to convert things and g g a
win for Duda Robert he is the winner of
his group no matter who you are things
are about to get very very real it's a
huge collapse from carwana it all went
downhill and Dimitri on draken punches
his ticket in unreal fashion at stake a
trip to the finals in Toronto and a
clean shot at the largest first place
prize of the year a brilliant game and
that is a ticket booked by friends it's
the cgc round of 16. who's headed to
Toronto it's time to find out
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave this is the round of 16 today
we will figure out who rounds out the
bracket and who are the final two will
be booking their tickets to Toronto I'm
your host Grandmaster Daniel nariditsky
alongside me today man the myth the
legend International Master Levy Rosman
Levy top of the morning to you are you
as excited as I am about the two matches
that we have in front of us today yeah
I'm super excited listen it's been
months of this event from the qualifying
stage now down to this round of 16
before we all go to Toronto to watch
eight of the world's best try to become
the first chess.com Global Champion
presented by Brave I don't know if the
title is also going to be presented by
brave but let's just say it is uh today
we've got our remaining two matches okay
so today we've got four guys and they
are fighting for two spots two to round
out our round of eight I'm super excited
we've got a lot of different interesting
story lines to get into but before we do
that I'll uh I'll let you take us
through some of the logistics
indeed well we will start with the round
of 16 bracket but before that we wanted
to give a quick shout out to our friends
at Brave who will be with us as our
presenting sponsor for the rest of the
cgc including all the way through to
Toronto we are excited to have Brave
with us we are also excited to be
viewing the round of 16 bracket as some
of the players have already booked their
tickets at nishkiri Lavon
aronianakamura JKD Wesley so and Dimitri
I'm draken will be with us in Toronto
but the other two spots are up for grabs
Levy when you look at this bracket what
are your sort of General thoughts what's
what words come to mind uh when you look
at the blood that has been spilled thus
far well I think I I think in terms of
blood spilled it's you know moves on an
online digital board and then folks sort
of very calmly and gently logging off of
a computer but uh yes it's definitely
been a crazy crazy ride up until this
point we can start anywhere but if if we
just start on the left side of the
screen it's everything that you would
expect you would expect certain people
like Hikaru and youngstov Duda to be
seated as number one and they emerge as
the winners of their group without a
huge struggle of much at all you go a
little bit further down Wesley so
winning the closest of matchups you
could even argue he should have lost
that match to Jeffrey Zhang well he
didn't all right he disappointed you uh
and he snatched Victory from the jaws of
defeat to emerge Dimitri and draken on
the other hand has just been incredible
winning in three versus Fabiano caruana
you look at the right side of your
screen uh pankrative was the Cinderella
story Anish giri put that story to bed
and kissed it good night as Anish has
been incredible to watch in all of his
matchups winning matches with really no
struggle whatsoever and now today he is
going to be keenly observing nepo versus
rajab uh dingly run versus nihal sarin
is fascinating Dania because one thing
that we discovered that maybe nobody in
the chat even knows yet is they have
never ever played a chess game against
each other can you is that real
I'm just like I hear that said every
time and it doesn't register in my mind
and we will get to all of the stats from
their individual matchups today we have
indeed two matches dingley ran against
nihal Sarah never faced off before and
yam Nepal Nishi against timurujabov who
have faced off many times before both of
these are Elder Statesman they are over
30 years old but you know if you just
look at the moves that they play you
will realize that they may be advanced
in age okay that's kind of false as well
but they are most certainly not losing
the fire on the chessboard Levy I mean
we've had days with four matches today
we have two matches but it's really not
about the quantity of matches the
quality of today's matches is going to
be incredibly High yeah it's going to be
incredibly High even if it will be
geriatric in your own words no I'm just
kidding they're playing from the old
folks home actually yeah actually yeah
they just checked into the retirement
home basically we've got two really
interesting story lines but before we do
that just take a step back we've got
four names on this screen three of them
just played in the candidates the entire
Allure of the cgc has been who is going
to be the new fresh talent that emerges
who is going to be the interesting story
nihal sarin just beat a multiple time
world champion and he is in my opinion a
top four top five Blitz player in the
world when you talk about 3-0 especially
in the online format number three is
probably sitting right here uh on the
screen with me uh and uh yeah that
that's really the fascinating thing here
we don't know nepo rajab of dingley
Rodney Hall Saran I don't know what will
happen in these matchups but I can
definitely tell you that I keenly await
to see if nihal sarin will be that name
if he is going to be that guy the young
teenager from uh India who is supposed
to be The Prodigy is supposed to be the
future well let's see it today dingley
runs the second best chess player in the
world in classical and a world
championship Contender let's not forget
no what an incredible four players we
have on display today let's take a look
at the individual matchup cards starting
with the match between Jan upanishi AKA
nepo and Timur or job of yan well he's
not used to being the younger of the two
but see more a job of at 35 years old
has over 20 years of experience at the
very highest level he defeated Gary
Kasparov in a classical game of chess in
2003 and ever since he has uh just sat
firmly among the highest echelons of
Chess power uh their head to head score
a lot of draws nepo leads significantly
both in Rapid he's won one classical
game and never lost In classical Levy
we're not debating that nepo is the
favorite here he is the favorite
especially after his recent string of
incredible performances which never
seems to stop but Timur job of one of
those guys who is consistently
underrated even though
you know even though his resume is
unimpeachable
no it's not uh yes it is no it's not
unimpeachable I don't know there's too
many yeses and no's in there but yeah
it's essentially in short I completely
agree uh and once these guys are done
getting their hip replacement surgery
because they're so old as you said
to uh bring their best chest today
listen Yan uh I chose in our bracket
preview several months ago to win this
entire event and to win this entire
event you have to win your group to win
your group you have to beat rajab of the
logic speaks for itself I'm not picking
a favorite in this matchup I'm simply
saying that one man right now I think is
playing at a just a slightly slightly
higher level which is all you need at
the top 10 top five of the world and
this is going to be a super close
matchup it might get decided with four
combative draws and then an Armageddon
but this is what we came to see number
one versus number two it literally
doesn't get any closer than that
it does not and the other matchup well
you could argue that it's more lopsided
as the Chinese number one dangleren
faces nihal sarin but anybody who has
spent any amount of time in the online
chess landscape Levy you pointed out
that nihal siren definitely I would say
top five three plus o players online his
performances uh in the jscc in the SCC
where he defeated the likes of Alexander
grishek they speak for themselves and
they do not happen by accident and let's
not pretend that nihal sarin is not an
incredible over the board player that
his opening repertoire is not at a 2700
level because it most certainly is he
might not have crossed 2700 feet a just
yet but nobody wants to face nihal sarin
in an important match do you agree with
that sentiment I think except maybe for
dingly Ren right I feel like some of
these players they they're they're not
afraid of their opposition they're not
afraid of the young guys uh the most
fascinating thing about this player card
is have not played h2h like they should
have just put n a there's no data
available and the craziest thing is
they've never played Blitz and they've
never played bullet if you do a search
on chess.com between nihal sarin and
Chef's house which is dingleren's
username it's literally nothing
they have never played which is that's
so crazy it's like that doesn't happen
name another top 50 matchup well I don't
know maybe there's going to be way more
than we expect but the fact that these
guys have literally never played against
each other this is so fascinating I have
absolutely no clue what to expect uh
will doing lorenge is basically do the
2800 level thing and just steamroll will
nihal sarin put up a fight he put up a
crazy fight against Vladimir kramik I
don't know man I'm so glad we're here
I've got just I've got no expectations
for this match I'm just gonna let the
moves uh take us along this journey
I mean it's going to be incredible the
community is pumped for these matches as
well they have assigned very clear
favorites the community has spoken they
think dingley Ren and Ian the Palm issue
are going to be the final two players
who booked their tickets to Toronto 96
Levy that's a pretty drastic prediction
I get it done is Young he is a very safe
bet Levy I think he was your bet to win
the entire event uh in our free cgc
predictions
but man the crowd seems really confident
that we won't have an upset today I was
trying to sneak it don't drink no no no
no no no no no no you dare I saw what
you were doing there that's why I I was
trying to I was trying to get it in
before we got back on screen I saw the
full screen anyway um yeah I was trying
to get a little something miles coffee
there but uh listen people think that
Jana's gonna win right whether it's 96
of people or 83 percent of people people
have favorites in these matchups I have
made fun of some of these predictions
because they've been so lopsided but
most of them honestly come true it
doesn't matter if they come true in the
Armageddon or they come true in three
games uh some have been ridiculous
Savion was one of the famous ones that
uh scored the victory despite being a
massive Underdog but if the community
thinks they're going to win you still
have to play unfortunately you do not
just get to win based on votes Giannis
clearly the favorite Yan is very clearly
the best chess player in the world in my
opinion not named Magnus Carlson You
could argue dingley Ren is tied right
there with him so like I said you want
to win the whole thing you got to win
your group to win your group you got to
beat two more
and when the more you've got to be no
that logic see the problem is that
sounded so so smooth and I wanted to
continue it but I can't and so the big
question today who is going to be on
Expedia or on kayak or on Google flights
this evening looking for tickets to
Lester B Pearson International Airport
will it be will it who will it be will
be will it be nihal sarin will it be
ding liren it's going to be an epic
showdown today as we have two
mouth-watering matchups on the docket
and before we jump in a quick reminder
ladies and gentlemen uh of the format
but before we even do that Levy well any
any overall thoughts
uh my thoughts are that the entire
purpose of the chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave
originally originally it was just
chess.com Global Championship from
conceptualization now presented by Brave
which obviously is going to be our
sponsor to the end of the whole thing uh
we have been asking the question of who
who is going to be in the eight right
folks if you got into chess in the last
couple of years or maybe you got into
chess uh prior to that you know that
every event seemingly has the same names
in it was the cgc going to be a
continuation of that well today we have
a situation where three of four just
played in the candidates in fact two of
the four who are going to be playing
today will be playing for the next World
Chess Championship Match will nihal
sarin spoil the party of the elite chess
players as they want to make a final
eight in Toronto uh or will they just
assert their dominance show their
strength and say we are not ready to
give up the Old Guard that's what I'm
expecting today what do I expect from
the matchup between nihal versus ding I
don't know I'm going to be watching it
as a commentator but more than anything
else I'm going to be watching it as a
chess fan uh and uh I'm gonna get all
their autographs if we can in Toronto
and one more thing I how the hell did
you know the name of the airport in
Toronto by heart did you like just book
your tickets no I'm sort of an airport
nerd and when I was a kid I really liked
exploring different airports and what
their codes were and what they were
called so I have actually known that
Toronto Airport name for like for years
it's it's one of the ones that I know
the extent of my nerdiness is getting
revealed in case anybody had any doubts
yeah yeah well you know what you know
what I used to do
um so I used to be able to walk down the
street and if I saw the edge of a
taillight of a car I could tell you what
car it was wow so you're like my brother
yeah the long-lost Brothers cars
airports it's it's all the same anyway
the format the format if you don't know
what the format is then where on earth
have you been but if you aren't joining
us late we wanted to remind you that
this is a four game match the time
control 15 minutes with a two second
increment the first to two and a half
wins and in the event of a 2-2 tie we
have an Armageddon where black receives
raw odds we've had so many armageddon's
already Levy everybody loves a good
old-school Armageddon are we going to
get one today well there's only one way
to find out isn't there
yeah there is only one way to find out
I'm definitely predicting an Armageddon
in the match between nepo and Timor I
feel like those Styles very much cancel
each other out
um how I what were their head to heads
on the candidates by the way did they
make two draws or did Nepal win a game
something I should have looked up
yeah I I feel as though I feel as though
it was two draws but obviously Timor did
not win because nepo hasn't lost the
game of classical actually uh well he
didn't lose in that event
um but uh yeah it's going to be
four rapid games it obviously could be
as short as three we've seen matchups
here even in the round of 16 decided in
three rapid games such as Lavon beating
Savion or such as andrekin beating
karawana but uh overall uh as far as I'm
concerned the most interesting matchup
hands down is the England versus nihal
simply for the fact that we have two
elite players that have never played
against each other and I think you're
precisely right I think those are the
two things that I pointed out uh in
preparation for the cgc the two things I
was looking forward to perhaps the most
generational matchups kramnik against
nihal you know vishy Anand who
unfortunately didn't last very long and
lost to a player from his generation in
aval pencada of one of the incredible
stories of the cgc is going to be
remembered even though he didn't quite
manage to make it uh into the final
eight but uh the second thing Levy are
match-ups that have never been held
before we know that in top level chess
the same people kind of played other
over and over again it's always
interesting but we don't have enough
inflow of slightly lower rated Juniors
that's why tournaments like the Olympiad
uh where you see unique matchups and uh
you know tournaments like the US
Championship that we're watching right
now is so interesting it's not a secret
it's because you have new matches and
you have the top guys facing people who
are bloodthirsty who are not afraid of
them and who are looking to show Levy
that the top 10 you know isn't like this
mystical Mount Olympus that you can't
climb to
right that's exactly the case and I
think what's important and what's
fascinating about Chess here in 2022 uh
well almost 2023 is the fact that we've
always Quantified skill level in chess
with ELO so what your rating is is what
your strength is that's not true anymore
that's literally complete nonsense now
we have players who are separated by 150
points who are the same level we have
players who are separated by 150 points
once one might be better than the other
one side just might not have an
opportunity to play as many games and
one might be hungrier than the other all
right one might study more than the
other that's just the way it goes in
fact we're seeing in a classical now
some of the old guards some of the
former number two number three number
four players are down to 15 and 16.
they're at their lowest rating in years
it's just sort of what happens it's like
The Changing of the Guard the young
hungry teenagers with more resources to
chess than ever more access to chess
content than ever and I'm not talking
like you know my YouTube content or well
no they probably do watch your speed
runs I feel like they you know even if
they're 27.50 they can learn something
from naroditsky absolutely uh absolutely
believe that truly in my heart but end
of the day we're on syrup before the
games have started uh well speaking of
which I'm gonna I'm gonna boost your ego
a little bit more can you please tell
the audience your final score yesterday
uh many of you may not know this Daniel
played a blitz match yesterday against
Magnus Carlson uh and what was the score
Daniel
all right it was uh 24 and a half to 30
and a half Magnus won I did not manage
to win although I was leading four and a
half one and a half I took out my phone
just shamelessly take some photos when
that was happening because I knew the
losses would start eventually but it was
six hours that I will probably not
forget anytime soon
yeah and uh I mean you know you went you
went for a six hour marathon there with
Magnus he almost split 50 the third best
3-0 player in the world right here as
far as I'm concerned I always say it's
Magnus Hikaru and neridynski and it
ain't even close I think you're the best
thing Daniel would you I'm actually I'm
not gonna make you agree with this I'm
just gonna say this right now over any
six hour period I think you are the best
30 second player in the world
true or false I mean I think I think
alireza uh and I would probably split
split
okay uh since and Andrew Tang I would
say you know used to be better but you
know Andrew's focusing on a slightly
more important things like college so I
would probably put myself on the top
three I'd have to agree with you as much
as I hate I know like what come on
you're not playing 30 seconds chess all
day what a loser
uh dude I I mean 30 second really it is
uh it is one of these things that even
with consistency you you improve I mean
it sounds ridiculous but I remember back
in the day I would just for fun grind an
hour or two of 30 second or bullet and
you just yeah you get rock solid ad you
get super sharp in it you don't do it
for a while you come back your hand is
slow your brain is slow everything is
slow uh and
um I think we have the players here
slowly loading into their games but uh
yeah I mean in the meantime you went 50
50 almost with Magnus Carlson that's uh
that's that's amazing and take me you
you and I discussed this when we
recorded the podcast episode together
but like your emotions of like getting
the opportunity to just be with Magnus
for six hours
to play you what does that feel like I
know a lot of people oh you're you're
fanboying you're simping like yes and
yes because this is Magnus Carlson the
greatest player who's ever lived so when
you hear that accept sound you know that
chess.com click when somebody accepts
your challenge I was watching hikaru's
stream so I assumed somebody had
accepted a blitz match against him and I
see okay Magnus Carlson is black Daniel
nerdinski is white it takes a second
just to register that you are actually
playing me just accepted a challenge
drop everything my phone is off my other
monitor is off blinds are closed the
match is on and I just can't transmit
the level of concentration that it takes
to literally not lose every game but
that's what I live for I mean it
produces such a rush every second that
you know he's spending playing you
rather than playing somebody else the
way I was thinking about it I wanted to
make it worth his while because you know
he's easily bored as the greatest player
on earth you're going to be easily bored
and my goal was to keep him interested I
think I managed to do that and I think
these two matches are going to keep us
interested because on that note
Levy Rosman the games have kicked off
dingley run with the white pieces
thank you for being so kind to me you
are going to be making me making me
blush all coverage long but I'm gonna
try to cover the games yeah we have a
tarash defense here from nihal I mean
this is like one of the most forceful
ways you can play a Queen's Gambit
declined in fact as early as move one
and two uh this is not 19th century
chess anymore I mean D4 D5 C4 E6 is
almost very rarely seen right like if
you're going to play e65 nowadays you're
gonna do it in a different move order
but this this has been seen a handful of
times in fact Tanya this was seen really
recently at some very elite level what
was the game do you know what I'm
talking about I swear we just saw the
slide might have even been an over the
board
you're putting me out I don't I don't
remember fill me in oh oh yeah so you're
you remember that there was a top level
game but you don't remember which one
yes yes uh I'm gonna try to find it
maybe
let's see I feel like it happened like
like a week ago or something okay very
interesting as you're finding it we're
having a lot of Transformations here in
the pawn structure C5 C4 by black that
was a really really big move so we're
not going to get an isolated Queen Pawn
position which could have Arisen if
White had taken the pawn on C5 when he
had a chance but the drawback of the
structure is of course the D5 Pawn which
black must keep as well protected as
possible especially in light of the fact
that the Knight on F6 has been
uh is is dignity run about to play F4
yeah
oh never mind oh oh lots of Trades what
do you make of this look at Black's king
size
yeah Black's King side looking a bit
suspicious although King h8 Rook G8
might be on the way and nehal might
argue that actually it's White's King's
side that looks suspicious yeah I really
I was about to say Bishop F3 Knight E2
looks really clever
um to render the bishop on B4 completely
useless but this is a massive massive
Risk by by nihal he's not looking to
stabilize with black he's looking to to
instigate
he's looking to win game one I mean it's
very very clear in his opening Choice
the way he's playing he wants to
unbalance this game and put nihals are
in uh and put dingling around on the
spot uh for minute one of this match
King G7 as he continues to Blitz out his
moves Levy this reeks of preparation you
just don't play a move like this unless
you've seen it before especially not in
two seconds yeah this is he's played
every move instantly
um he actually nihala has played this
himself
in the Olympiad he played like this
um but the game went completely
differently so I think mihal has some
very good preparation here in fact he
played this against Malcolm Young in the
Olympiad and then last year he played
this in another over the board game and
he beat Parham maxulu like in a
classical back in a classical game holy
so nihal really likes the taraj
defense I mean he really really likes it
and um
A4
you almost never see the move A4 blade
when there is a bishop sitting on B4
like 99 of the pawn they kind of a pawn
is touched it goes to A3 Levy
yeah that's a fascinating move as the
idea like A5 what is the idea what is it
so two things I think maybe one of the
ideas is to prevent black from playing
B5 so that later on when white plays the
move B3 it comes with greater effect
because black can't easily support the
pawn so maybe we'll see something like
Rook C1 as weird as it seems to prepare
B3
but I agreed I agree with you A5
definitely was an idea and that's why I
need help played 86.
yeah and I and nihal is is playing this
super aggressively okay Bishop Bishop
back to D6 I mean listen so fast I know
I know so quickly I wonder what what are
the next few moves by black does black
want F5 is that something that black is
interested in
yeah I'm trying to figure that out as
well F5 does hem in the bishop and I
kind of I'm partial to this idea of
playing Rook GA dropping the king back
and then maybe later down the line
having Bishop H3 or Bishop G4 ideas
kingside attack along the G file has got
to be one of Black's main ideas I mean
why otherwise did you accept the ruin of
your own kingside Pawn struck so I'm
leaning towards saying no on the F5
front which is probably why anyhow is
going to play F5 in the next
is there B3 here
or is there no B3 because there's
because there's C3 and if Knight C3
there's Bishop H2 I don't but I don't
know
let me show that on the analysis board
that's a cool line I think ding is gonna
play B3 so C3 very creative idea Knight
C3 what Bishop yeah
yeah the problem is okay beautiful dark
chocolate good and nice but you're still
stuck with the damage structure and yeah
when you have a damage structure most
peace trades are going to be in White's
favor here because the King on H2 uh is
now feeling phenomenal so yeah what is
nihal's idea after B3 well Abby maybe he
just wants to play Rook a C8 to support
the farm
mm-hmm thanks
[Music]
but okay indeed speaking of but okay uh
I believe that we have the opening moves
uh or just about to get underway in the
uh in the nepo versus rajaba matchup
um I think all players are already there
um but uh I yeah maybe we can pop on
over
let's pop on over
yep we've got okay we have uh actually
that that was unexpected wow whoa
yeah this is this is rare because wait a
minute when's the last time Jana allowed
a nimso with white I know and he's been
playing the Catalan just automatically
really in all online events like
exclusively preparation no preparation
not only does he allow the nimso levy
it's not just a queen c2m so an E3 Nim
so he plays the sharpest line available
the samish variation with four F3 what a
choice
yeah this is the one of the sharpest
lines it's not good it's not uh it's not
good for white if your goal is to get an
advantage according to stockfish there
are multiple ways for black to equalize
but it is so sharp and with modern day
technology oh
sorry no no no no no I I'm with you I
don't
I was about to say with modern day
technology you you can instigate with
black but like as you see even what was
the move there like what what did the
computer hate about that move so Bishop
F4 definitely is the man I wasn't just
parodying the Eva but I promise Bishop
F4 is just very rare in this position
the move let's bring up an analysis
board here real fast Timur reacted too
quickly because it appears that after
edcd what is the drawback of the bishop
on F4 Knight coming to H5 why is that so
dangerous you might ask Bishop comes
back to E3 is it because of Queen H4
check no the bishop dropped back to F2
it's because of F5 and Levy with white
king side entirely undeveloped this is
borderline lost this is so weird yeah
this is super simple it's happening I
don't know uh by the way I just pulled
up I just pulled up a stat
um the amount of times in his life that
yanyupomnishi has been white in a nimso
is 17 times that's it and before before
2020 it had happened twice in 2017 and
then before that it was 2013 and then
back then you're talking 2009 2008 2007.
so he never does this he never played
and I mean in terms of F3 nimso uh I
would probably argue never
and you know what he's thinking right
about now uh why exactly didn't I play
the Catalan because see more might not
have found the best move but he has
managed to open up the center you can
see the eval bar is absolutely not
buying the placement of the bishop on F4
Levy I mean that's the drawback of the
F3 name so you're creating major
weaknesses on the king side and so you
need to accelerate your kingside
development and I think nepo just
prioritized the wrong thing he's got the
wrong Bishop developed
I mean certainly this this must be
planned like he
he must he must have come to the game uh
ready to play this right I I uh
I I don't know
or nepo to be spending this long is a
sign that things have gone you know
mayday mayday
Bishop's really free now he starts
developing I mean I really wonder like
can can black sword yeah that's the
first move I'm thinking about
to look for you
no still not H5 and F5 looks very good
yeah
yeah seriously I'm yeah I I I also don't
know I also don't know
oh this is uh this is weird stuff I
don't know what's going on here this is
not what I expected but I know and it
just eat with which he played Bishop F4
indicates that it was crap I think nepo
is beginning to climb out of this if he
can manage to Castle
if he can manage to secure the C4 Pawn I
think he's going to be fine
but still definitely an opening scared
definitely an opening I don't think he's
going to be repeated
yeah probably not I think this was a
calculated risk I think he was like I'm
going to take a lot of risk in game one
and uh table would like if you if given
an opportunity to blow up the position
or slowly squeeze it take more is going
to slowly squeeze it right like nepo
will blow up a position if he thinks
that he is uh in a in a driver's seat
and I think that's sort of the game plan
here I think it's to make a mess and
then consolidate the mess and then win
which is really interesting right he's
basically saying it might be minus 0.8.9
but Timur is not going to go crazy
trying to attack me he's probably going
to try to like play Slow improving moves
and kind of get a positional grind uh
and uh well there's Knight H5 so we may
have an answer very soon out in so far
as you can talk about you know these top
players having a weakness fritzy Moore
you know you're absolutely right the
area of the game where he feels less
comfortable is in chaotic positions and
that is precisely where nepo thrives so
the game plan makes sense the way he's
gone about achieving this game plan
doesn't make as much sense to me and see
more turned a lot of heads when he
defeated ding in 20 moves at the
candidates teamwork was able to show
that he's not just gonna shy away from
tactical positions out of principle he
might take a little bit longer uh than
the average Super GM but he's not going
to you know trade Queens at all costs uh
or or shy away from a direct attack
against his opponent's king and I think
he's showing that in the way that he's
playing here Knight F6 to H5 his
intentions are pretty violent here
yep they are pretty violent F5 and queen
H4 are on the way I mean Timur made as
many improving moves as possible and he
basically ran out of them
the the next thing that he had to do was
get his Knight involved on the H5 Square
I really I really wonder what happened
in this game like what
what when Jan
played this opening very quickly what
was he expecting uh compared to what he
got now I don't I don't know because I
spent like 10 hours last year studying
the F3 nimso with white and it was just
a total total knife's edge of a position
if you even at some moments get out of
prep in this opening and don't do the
right thing you're just worse so for Jan
to deliberately go for something the
computer didn't give a blessing to
that's fine players do that sometimes if
the position is practically difficult
but Tanya you said it this doesn't look
that difficult practically for black
no listen I think he confused the line
Bishop C1 to f4 on move seven it's not a
move the move in that position uh is
Bishop D3 you want to develop your king
side as a matter of top priority
precisely because of what we're seeing
now where White's position is riddled
with holes Black's got clearly defined
play on the king side and you don't want
to get into a situation where you are
worse both positionally and tactically
what do I mean by that I mean your king
is less safe than you're posting and
your opponent has better control of key
squares in the position I think Timur he
can play as simply as Knight takes G3
Levy and queen F6 and then you've got
all sorts of threats against this
vulnerable Knight on C3 maybe nepo can
hold on by bringing his Rook to C1 in
timely fashion but he's not going to be
having fun for at least the next 10
moves
yeah he really isn't well I think his
fun depends on whether or not rajabov
allows him to have fun like I said at
the end of the day rajaba is going to be
the one determining whether the white
position is going to have fun or not
it's important to keep an eye on the
clock as well black has a one and a half
minute time Advantage which against Jan
can fade so quickly because you sort of
sit there and you're like okay I'm
better but how I'm better but how I'm
better but how wait a minute I'm down
six minutes on the clock I think yeah
exactly Jan and mvl are very similar in
that way they are fast Defenders right
so they try to get out of unpleasant
situations not by playing the board
always but also playing the clock and
making it perfectly difficult yeah so
that's a great call they're not just
fast and they're also fast and they're
defending that's actually a very
important point yeah because a lot of us
when we defend we get mad sad we sit
there we get no not these guys just play
moves they just play moves and by the
way it's down to 50 seconds now
he plays moves and he tries to confront
his opponent with practically difficult
decisions like here Bishop F4 to G3 take
me on G3 play Queen F6 you plan the king
side or do you maybe strike on the queen
side with a Banco Gambit style idea you
often see black playing B7 B5 and C5 C4
in these positions especially uh given
that this idea won't be as attractive
after White Castle's King side because
then the Knight will be able to take on
people
has just left the building
he's like man that position was so bad
I'm out you know I'm uh I'm leaving
yeah I can't I can't bear to look at
this so astimor is deciding on his next
course of action you think this is a
good time maybe to check back into our
other match yes yes let's check back in
uh let's take a look at dingley run
versus the Hassan and um Dingus ding is
doing what he's what he what he does
best he's trying to surgically exploit
certain problems of the position Rook A3
is an interesting move I wrote before
sorry it's an interesting move uh Queen
A2 and it's black have rookie four
it's not even a good move I don't
I don't have to wrap my head around like
What's Happening Here the one clear
determination I made is the D5 is
currently hanging unless I'm
hallucinating yeah but you could
Envision some situations in which black
actually sacrifices that pawn maybe if
it leads to a queen trade or a rook
infiltration to be too so I would not
rule out the Mover okay for even though
it sacrifices on maybe that's precisely
the kind of conditions under which you
want to sacrifice
yeah I
also think the Rook can go back to C4
this is such a tangled web of a position
yeah I mean there's so many pieces
staring at one another but look at nihal
four minutes up
very confident play from him
and he's just kind of a he's just kind
of a nightmare like I don't
he's just
so such a practical player and if we
bring up an analysis board for a second
I want to explore Roque for for a second
you propose that Levy I really like this
idea what happens after takes takes
Bishop takes D5 and just A3 I I don't
know about you I hate these types of
positions with white where you have to
deal with a pass Pawn that is in
eradicable you the only way you're going
to get rid of it is by sacrificing an
exchange on A3 and that's just not a
palatable option
yeah actually averages I've rejected my
original idea because I saw that D5 was
under attack but I mean in this kind of
a format with nine minutes on the clock
as opposed to like 20 seconds by the way
nihal would probably do this in a Blitz
game anyway but uh this looks really
really hard for white and it looks like
it will probably just be some sort of
end game where white has more pawns and
black has more material and it'll
probably just end up being a drop but
I mean but it's okay in the event of
betrayed the one becomes very active so
maybe white has to play something like
D5 here and try to get the Knight active
but I I can bet you a silver dollar that
knee-hal is calculating this very line
right now and because of the sunk cost
Levy you invest five six minutes it
makes it a lot more likely that you're
going to go for a line like this yeah
it's really frustrating when you
calculate for a long time and then
chicken out and then it turns out to be
the best move that's sort of like the
the the worst of the worst but these
players in these critical moments are
extremely accurate it's what gets them
to the round of 16 so it gets them to a
round of eight
um the best players in the world when
they take a lot of their time
percentage-wise they are going to
probably find that that critical idea
um you know there there is no concrete
reason to not play Rook A4 it's more of
a feeling right like nihal might not see
the concreteness of all of this seven to
eight moves down the line he it's very
tough like once you get deeper into end
games to calculate everything with no
with no time on the clock but you'll
play Rook A4 based on the feeling that
he gets sufficient compensation or the
lack of that feeling
yeah I mean you can just see the wheels
turning in his head and Rook to A4 what
a decision by nihal and this is why I
love watching him play it doesn't matter
who he's facing he's not going to shy
away from principled continuations if he
believes in his calculation guess what
he's playing the moves and that's what
makes this Young Generation so
ridiculously dangerous and terrifying to
play It's not that they don't respect
the top guys they respect them as chess
players but they're not going to change
the way they play just because the
number in front of your opponent's
hundred digit is an eight yep yep and
look at nehal A3 this is the line that
we were calculating I think dingley Wren
now realizes
uh he is going to have some serious
struggles defending this Pawn having
said that white still has some decent
practical chances but the evaluation I
can't see the number but it's around
zero right
zero point zero yeah and let's think
about that it's zeros but black is down
a pawn
so white is supposed to be plus one but
black has a full point of compensation
right here's the critical moment we saw
this whole line so what is nehal gonna
show us here that we haven't seen
already because white is about to play
Knight D4 okay Queen E4 but now still
Knight D4 right so what is nehal gonna
do then you have to prevent Rook c294 is
on the board but now Rook B8 and The
Rook is infiltrating to B2 oh my Lance
this is getting dangerous and here's
what's critical Levy Rook D2 not an
option because then The Rook slides to
B1 and white has to give the queen away
yeah oh my goodness wow so what was the
move instead of Knight D4 what was
stockfish saying there's 90 Pros if it
was a very like lazy and natural move
I mean the only move according to
stockfish let's bring up an analysis
board again Queen A1 check which in and
of itself isn't that crazy here's the
idea you're provoking F6 and then you're
sticking the Knight on F4 and going to
E6 if black drops back to G8 instead the
only path to a draw is Queen F6 black
and drop the queen back Queen G5 check
and now you're supposed to play 94 and
allow the pawn to get to A2 this is this
is inhuman I mean you have to find four
or five computer moves cold-blooded like
that yeah and and basically what we just
saw in front of us right we saw both
guys looking at the exact same thing
okay we saw both guys both analyzing
five moves deep if we can just go to the
live board and I think when dip so ding
played Knight D4 the way you and I is
also kind of lazily played Knight D4
because it looked like the natural move
ding-only look that moves falling down
the board like a waterfall toward him
but sidestepping with the Rook to go to
B2 I think that totally eluded him
because he wouldn't have played D4 if he
saw root B8 and that's sort of the level
difference at the highest uh chess
Echelon is you both see five moves but
one guy sees six all right or you both
see that move move six but you
misevaluated ding I think totally
miserable B8 and uh now he's gonna have
to defend this unpleasant position
and it's not totally lost I mean he is
going to mount a last stand on that A2
square and in some situations you know
if he can sack for the pawn and then win
also the F5 Pawn he will have serious
strong chances the big question here for
knee-hole does he want the Queens off
the board and if the answer is yes then
we're going to see Queen C4 what about
what about H5 or something I don't like
look at you but is Rook D4 a concern
right now
I guess the queen will be sent to every
which looks like a good Square uh Levy
but it doesn't have access to D1
or E2 but what's the move what's the H5
Rook D4 Queen F3 what is the move like
I'm missing it for sure I I don't know
what the move is but uh what is the move
for black in this position oh for white
in that position yeah yeah like H5 Rook
D4 Queen F3 can we put that on the board
I don't know if we can yeah we got an
analysis board going here
but okay moves are being played on the
board yeah oh my God what did he play
King G6
back to the live board we go King G6
Wireless
oh cause he got checked oh because he
got checked on A1 oh yeah but still to
not a lot of people would play F6 here I
don't want to put my king on G6 it's
scary it's actually the safest it's been
all game on G6 it's unassailable the
Knight can't reach it The Rook can't
reach it because this F5 Pawn is
providing excellent cover and guess what
Levy blackstroke is now inevitably going
to infiltrate to the second ring
yeah this is incredible the Knight on B3
is just completely defenseless it must
move it has got two zeros a very rare
case of two zero right it's basically
white gave a check removing the defense
of the Knight and now now white has to
move
um the crazy thing is if that black H7
Pawn gets to H4 white is now under
severe danger right now it's
you know it's uh it's just monitoring
the situation but once the pawn is on H4
and the defense is getting removed from
the white king the white King's sort of
been abandoned by the way it's only
pawns like the white king just says
bricks protecting the house that he
lives in okay every other piece is on
the other side of the board so uh H5 H4
is going to be on the way that house
might get knocked down and I love how
the black kings just like out in the
open just like not you know not not a
care in the world uh if nihal wins this
with black uh this is just exceptional
um but I don't want to call it yet
because obviously more chess has to be
played oh it's it's not over but ding
with every ticking second it sure looks
like it might be over he's got two
minutes
he's nowhere near uh I mean the defense
is just starting I mean nehal hasn't
even begun his initiative it'll really
begin the moment he puts his Rook uh on
B2 and it's not necessarily Levy the
black will win in two or three moves the
problem is that white doesn't have
superiority on any side of the board
he's dealing with the a Pawn on the
queen side and as you've been indicating
he's dealing with a potential March of
the h-man as well as a second rank
assault against the F2 on on the king
side so wherever you turn wherever your
eyes start uh you're basically getting
checkmated as I've been talking he's
dropped another 20 seconds and now he's
below two minutes he has a minute and 40
seconds 20 seconds to figure out this
game and and there there it goes I mean
that eval is gonna plummet you just
cannot defend this position with this
little time uh and you know what the
thing is nihal does not screw up
advantages very easily like nihal keeps
advantages that's that's that's the
problem for ding
no he his technique is excellent it's
one of the most impressive facets of his
very multi-faceted game the big question
here where is he going to put his Queen
my guess Queen C4 to E2 followed by Rook
V2 ding is trying to activate his Knight
as much as he can but Levy once The Rook
gets to be too the White Queen is going
to be totally hemmed in on A1 and
without the queen it's going to be very
difficult to get anything going against
black spawner absolutely right even if
black uh even if white does get the
Knight to C6 like what is the next move
I mean you have to rely on Knight E5
check maybe you really want to trade the
Knight for the bishop because then the
pawn on A3 loses a Defender I don't know
uh basically what white is hoping for is
to trade everything and get into a queen
end game and give Perpetual check I
don't think white can actually
realistically hope to win this game
anymore
um no white is on the defense and look
at that he plays a move stalkers just
stays right where it is because he
doesn't give up advantages
best move we need to it's actually the
only move uh to keep a plus three
advantage of Diggs clock continues to
take down
now it's Unstoppable what was the
difference between Queen C2 and queen E2
so the difference I think Queen C2
may be allowed in certain positions the
night to drop back to D4 with Tempo I'm
spitballing I actually have no idea
maybe it has to do with the fact that
the queen has easy access to F great uh
so that later on uh it's easier to
deliver a lobster pencer mate I'm not
sure I just think it's the optimal
placement in terms of being invulnerable
and maximizing its activity now there's
Queen takes he wanted a two oh my
goodness oh my lands
that's not even that hard spot that's
not even that hard to calculate
like it's not that hard to find because
you just see it yeah you you're like
well he's he's attacking my queen but
what if I take right like you what if I
take should go through your head even
without the pawn on A3 and you should
discard it in 0.1 seconds because the
queen is defending it okay because you
just need to look at what you can
capture but in this case you have a pawn
there and it's going to go to A2 and
rugby one the hollow's looking at the
ceiling not because he likes what's on
his ceiling he likes the fact that he
can attack his Queen for The Rook you
never know maybe he's got a copy of the
Sistine Chapel on the ceiling Queen
takes C1 Sensational from mihal sarin
the pawn has reached A2 and it's Total
Domination The Rook is getting to be won
and at best at best white can do
something like Knight B3 no this is I
think this is over
I don't understand how you stop but he's
resigned oh my goodness and he's
resigned
oh my goodness that was one of the most
dominant displays that we have seen in
this round of 16 winning with black
in 20 or so moves that was unbelievable
for nihal sarin my mouth is literally
open to defeat dingley ran like this
with that level of opening preparation
getting a structure that he knows
amazing but don't breathe because we
gotta switch to the other game I think
Jana punished his position is falling
apart breaking news ladies and gentlemen
team we're a job off is trying to take a
page out of nihal saran's book right now
wait a few moves ago was there Rook
takes on E2 is that what basically
happened there was
yeah oh my God look at timor's play B5
D5 open the files wow wow wow this is
like I am this is like if nepo was it's
like if colors were reversed I mean
Timur is playing in the way that had he
had that in his toolbox he would be
unstoppable right like he's turning the
clock back a little bit to hell with
solidity let's just blow open the
position I literally just said this 10
minutes ago and that is sort of what you
said that's what everybody says Timor is
very solid but in this game you're not
showing any of that he's just trying to
win at all costs
yes solid who said anything about solid
says Timor Bishop coming back to T4 Levy
right now there is a mate threat Bishop
D4 and queen H6
can we even talk about potential
comeback here for yawn I right now I
don't even know how he avoids uh
essentially having to give up a rook for
the bishop which is going to be an
immediate death sentence
yeah I don't know how how on Earth is
this plus two like can you play rookie
one and threaten back rank mate yourself
to kill some time oh he's just no you
have that's the right move you have to
play Rook takes E3 and Rook D1 great
practical chance for NEPA by the way
he's got to put all of his eggs in one
basket and that is the Pawn on D5 basket
he has to make something out of that
pawn right right right so basically the
way Timor has played this is he has
sacrificed multiple pawns and now nepo's
gonna try to use that to his advantage
and probably this will no longer be
decided by an attack on the king but
rather some sort of long-term end game
if nepo saves this game it's gonna be
such a psychological loss for for a job
of I mean it's like as bad as losing
and that's a Minefield right that's a
very unpleasant situation to be in where
now all of a sudden you basically have
to win or else you're going to be
incredibly mad at yourself
and nepo's only chance here I think is
to get to more let's say under two
minutes and I'm under two minutes keep
the pawn on D5 alive maybe find a way to
push it to D6 whatever you do do not
lose the D5 quad
if you lose the D5 Pawn the game is most
certainly over what is going on today we
have seen some yeah King f8 getting that
getting there yeah yeah that's another
excellent move by team we're using the
king kind of like a goalie who comes out
uh for that final corner kick all hands
on deck and black is very close to
getting the Queens swapped and if he
does that well that's
you know another piece of bad news for
white
yeah I'm not sure do you trade Queens
here with white because obviously you
don't want to trade because you're
losing on the other hand you understand
the significance that maybe you'll hold
a rook and pawn end game with an extra
Bishop but I I don't know I don't know
what you do here the black queen is so
active
I guess it depends on where you trade
Queens like but but the problem is even
after a move like Queen C4 even if it's
the conditions for the queen trade are
optimal
I mean you think about that position the
black king gets to D6 blockades the plot
all avoids inside pawns are gonna be on
light squares there's no way nepo is
holding up look at the clock
nepo has two and a half minutes it's
even more has four I can repeat that
five times and you wouldn't believe me
if I said that coming into this game
especially given that yam has the white
piece
this opening experiment has been
a fiasco
absolutely Fiasco absolutely and
yeah nepo was a bit shaky in that
matchup versus Fiddler but at least he
got the job done in the Armageddon but
this is a completely different story I
mean Timur has played some amazing
chess in recent weeks and it is on Full
display here and it only continues
continues indeed he blockades the D6
spawn a very careful move Bishop D7 it's
still not over John is doing everything
he can uh you know to keep a glimmer a
spark alive
he still got he still has the D6 spawn
Levy as long as he's got a passer I'm
willing to say that the game is not over
ah I don't know you're like that's kind
of over I kind of feel I kind of feel
like it might be over yeah I'm not
exactly sure how you're going to get
yourself out of this situation but the
thing is in chess you don't just get the
winning position and win you actually
have to take it all the way down and
maybe rookie five maybe a rookie six to
try to get the Rook to the H file
attacking the white king I mean Nepal's
just chucking pawns now trying to push
the rest of the pieces through so I
think I'm snag I think it's time to eat
I think you take on B5 because D7 is not
to be feared rookie Aiden you know the
only effect of that is that white
accelerates uh the defeat by losing the
pawn faster I think Timor well no he
goes for Levy rosman's idea what a
terrible decision oh it's awful awful
awful
um
you know I uh I always say when the
players take my ideas
maybe not a good thing although in this
case computer seems to like it and also
there are various opportunities like
Queen E5 check to try to win the pawn on
D6 in fact Queen E5 right now what what
is this F4
only move I think
okay then you could play something if
you want to trade Queens you can play 23
there I think that's really what Jana's
gonna rely on he's going to rely on like
an incorrect decision to simplify and I
think white will Chuck a couple pawns to
win the C5 Pawn well we'll try to play
Rook D5 Rook C5 at which point white has
a very small chance of saving this game
microscope oh oh Donya
clock going on clock clock two minutes
what did I say when he's under two
minutes that's when he starts biting his
shirt
and all you need is that little glimmer
of anxiety you know that oh am I
actually am I starting to screw this up
am I giving my opponent unnecessary
chances
G5 a G5
what a classy move just totally freezing
all of White's King side pawns
preventing F4 I still think Timor has
this under control now he's got to try
to stay over one minute
yeah one minute is more than enough with
a two second bonus in a scramble of an
end game white has chances okay yeah
yeah this is like full time John's lost
hope we need fiber takes d601
okay
yeah there's no there's no there's
nothing here
sorry go on I was gonna say after Queen
E5 Queen G3 I'm just trying to tell
everybody there's Rook H6 right so
that's the idea
that's a very important detail by the
way that would precisely be the kind of
uh wrong simplification because white
could get the Rook to D5 also note that
Queen takes B3 was a total possibility
A4 as you said is a complete
it's just frustration yeah you can sort
of tell by the amount of times that Jan
has sort of like made a made a face with
his eyes and his lips that he is uh he's
kind of at the end of his patience for
this position and um
yeah he's he's certainly unhappy and it
was an experiment and it certainly
didn't pay off now I don't know I don't
know why it went this bad to begin with
i he made a very deliberate attempt to
play one of the sharpest lines of the
nimso Indian and
you're saying he might have even
misplayed it to get to the situation
Bishop F4 I'm I will stand by my claim
that was a terrible move it was some
sort of miscal confusion I don't know
what it stemmed from but that was not
the move and it wasn't one of those
moves this is what's so important not
one of those moves oh the computer
doesn't approve of it but it's
practically interesting practically it's
just terrible and look at this Rook D1
and queen E1 is going to be check and
mate after the king moves or White can
choose to lose this queen with check
choose your pick Napo chooses a third
option as he throws in the towel what a
tour de force Levy this is shades of uh
rajabov's win over ding that's what this
reminds me of yeah this is your moves
yeah this is her job of saying uh stop
describing me as a solid player stop
describing what you think is potentially
a flaw of my game I am more than capable
of winning games in a multitude of
different styles and really I I think
the thing is if you underestimate
rajaba's Dynamic skills Dynamic
abilities and you play some kind of
absurd opening against them he will
punish you to the depths of absolute
defeat the craziest part about this
round is we just saw two absolutely
dominant start to finish victories by
black not just by black but by the
players in the match who were not given
a chance in the community vote
yeah I mean what people seem to forget
is that you cannot hit 27.50 and stay
there for decades unless you are a
ridiculously well-rounded player a
player who is constantly able to adjust
on the Fly and speaking of adjusting on
the Fly maybe it's time to adjust your
browsing experience we wanted to thank
our sponsor brave because Brave means
private browsing and so much more by
default Brave locks ads and trackers on
every page and video you visit even on
YouTube no ads means up to three times
faster page loads faster streaming and
faster playback it means 35 percent
longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com
chess well the global Chess Championship
presented by Brave will return with game
two after a sensational start to both
matches by the player with the black
pieces don't go anywhere game two coming
your way on the other side of this short
break
run for my life
okay
what's up man hey just solving some
puzzles
get my coffee
oh shoot
which one is that is that our new one
yeah
I can't get this one man
oh shoot
what's wrong with you man
this is hard
you sure you're feeling okay
uh one got it oh shoot
thank you
I should say T1
foreign
we are back at the chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave where
Jana pamushi as well as dingly Wren have
just suffered devastating defeats in
John's case at the hands of a
bloodthirsty Timur rajabov as we look at
Yan's pensive just uncomfortable facial
expression Yan at 32 years old Levy he's
so experienced he's been in these
situations before how does he recover
mentally how does he recover on the
chessboard what advice would you give
him if you're his boxing coach
boxing coach uh you're the guy in the
ring you know
um well I I don't know actually if Yan
has found himself behind in many matches
early I think Jan is a fast starter his
whole thing is can he keep the
consistency throughout and kind of not
lose his path uh I think Jan
is in a very unique position right now
and I think Champions are made in a
variety of different ways best analogy I
can give you UFC champion Charles
Oliveira has won his last three
championship fights and he's constantly
he's been knocked down in every single
one of them a punch has landed he's
dropped to the ground he's gotten back
up
um I think Yom can chalk that game up
not to any sort of Chess skill but
rather I played some nonsense in the
opening for the next few rounds I am not
going to play nonsense in the opening
but the truth is at the highest level of
the game more often than not games will
end in draws when you have to win that
is when things get weird so will he try
to go all in immediately in game two
will he try to follow the philosophy of
stop the losses right away and try to
win with white in game three I don't
know but we are most certainly going to
find out he has lost games in his life
uh but he generally does not get blown
off the board so not like that yep I I
don't remember the last time you lost a
game like that and knowing Yan I think
he's going straight for the win
the problem with that Levy is that if
you lose this game you go down to zero
we haven't had a 2-0 comeback in all of
the cgc and I don't think we will I
think with this caliber of players it's
virtually impossible and you can see
already a very clearly defined strategy
by Timor we've made his soil you know
Soviet Schoolboy approach doesn't want
to get into the semi-terrush he wants a
symmetrical solid position and I love
that strategy or it's more because
that's going to serve to Tilton even
more wasn't D5 here played by Hikaru
versus Lanier or was that a slightly
different move order I think that that
that happened a bit yeah
I think it was I remember that game yeah
but I think White had castled instead of
playing A3 but all these move orders
just confuse me ultimately ooh Bishop E2
though I'm used to the bishop dropping
back to A2 in these positions precisely
so that D5 remains on the table Yeah
like if you eat two I don't know if
you've already played A3 you should go
to A2 but if you haven't played A3 like
that's the thing right in this position
like the fact that white has played A3
makes it so that Bishop A2 is possible
but uh the way he did it now can black
even maybe make it really unbalanced
like C4 it's an option maybe in some
positions CD4 also but
yeah I mean listen CD4 and Bishop B7 is
usually not an option with the bishop on
A2 because white has D5 actually I want
to pull up in an elsewhere that's an
instructive Point Bishop A2
um takes takes Bishop B7 you're one move
away from blockading the pawn but white
pushes D5 with a huge initiative with
the bishop on E2 C takes D4 is always
going to be on the table but Levy I
agree with you C4 also uh definitely to
be taken seriously
yeah C4 just shut the door okay please
Bishop B7 now you see
yeah this is the problem and before
and draw
now I think it's just it's just totally
symmetrical after B4 and Bishop B2
yeah this is not this is not great I
guess nepo is not taking the strategy of
when it all costs which kind of makes
sense if you lost a rough game you would
you equalize with black
but uh it's gonna win at some point
he's gotta win at some point the game
isn't over after B4 and Bishop B2 I just
don't see Tim who are losing that
position I just don't
it's just so symmetrical and there's a
high probability of total liquidation on
the queen side with at some point White
playing A4 and then B5 and if the queen
side pawns were traded you might as well
sign the beats
yeah I mean if anybody's gonna win it's
going to be white because in positions
of total symmetry let's not forget white
goes first and white begins to ask all
the questions you know so
um
in this case Jan is uh
yeah yeah it looks really unhappy but I
don't know maybe he just looks focused
but
yeah always hard to say but he's you're
right Levy he hasn't been in the spot
forever and and that's the definition of
suffering from success I mean you just
like forget what it's like you'd be down
in a match and to be playing poorly and
you'll oftentimes lose patience with
yourself
you know you saw that with sports teams
like the Warriors my love dearly
you know last season they had a couple
of games where they were down you know
and 15 points at the half and they just
kind of had a melt out because just not
used to being in that situation
psychologically let's see how Jan
handles this
yep uh has the other game started by the
way because I'm kind of bored
we have anything out
oh they haven't said it yet okay
okay we're you're stuck with this one
I'm sorry to say uh they might literally
draw in like five or ten moves I don't
think Jan has any interest in playing
this position for I mean it's almost
completely symmetrical
it is I mean if anything I think Tim
Moore should be on the lookout for
chances to seize the advantage because
if you're frustrated you're like ah man
I didn't create any chances John has
been known at times
uh you know to make a couple of careless
moves but we'll keep an eye on this game
I have some very good news for you Levy
uh we have another channel on the
television it's called the dingly ren
nehal sarin Channel yep and we are going
to switch to that channel yes wow look
at this this is uh this is some sort of
meta so C3 has really gotten popular
recently because it's a way to move
order black into a better London you're
aware of this I'm sure like generally if
you play Bishop f4 on the third move
black can play the immediate C5 then
considered totally fine for black but C3
deliberately makes black make a move
first to make C5 impossible now black
could still play C5 and then you get a
reverse note boom variation which is
just one of the most insane variations
in all of Chess uh I had that recently
in an over the board game uh and it was
an it was a disaster I I didn't remember
the line at all I had to basically make
it up uh over the board my opponent knew
20 moves of theory
um it's a very annoying line and you see
ding is pausing here not because he
doesn't know any chest pass move three
but uh you know uh it's a tough line
it's an annoying line and it's clearly
Hall wants to play a London
and
an analysis board because I want to show
what the notebook variation actually is
uh C7 C5
D takes C5 and the point of C3 Levy
correct me if I'm wrong becomes clear
after E6 because here you're able to
play before and I think the actual
notebook structure arises after
something like this eight Stakes B6 A4
you give up C5 and you push B5 and all
of a sudden you actually have connected
passers on the A and B files which is
pretty crazy uh by move nine you haven't
even put your clothes on in the morning
and you're already dealing with two
connected password this is not palatable
for most players especially not for
dingley run if we go back to the live
board he has avoided this scenario by
first playing C uh E6 then pushing C5
yes and as is very typical Levy Queen's
on B3 and B6 right see that on the daily
in the London yes but the benefit now is
that nehal has forced ding into playing
uh a certain setup right he's forceding
into playing Just One of the variations
of the London where these Queens meet on
the B file nobody wants to capture the
other Queen because the a file is going
to open for the rook and ding has
already played a massive sideline he's
played Bishop D7 which like I've never
seen before for example I mean
everything in the London is like 0.2 for
white right uh this is no no exception
and the Knight on B8 hasn't even moved
so Bishop E2 yeah this is just a London
like at some point nehal will probably
play H3 Castle Knight E5 one of these
three moves
um this is so londony it's just like it
just London to its core you know if you
want a position if you're playing
Pictionary or something
uh or you're trying to
send martians a universally
understandable signal of what the London
is I would just give this
yep maybe maybe right before 95 but yeah
for for for newer players you know we
try to teach London with Bishop on D3
Queen is going to the king side for
checkmate but these guys they're not
going to get checkmated in the London
white is just going to get a slightly
unpleasant position and black basically
has to sit there and prevent themselves
from throwing a tantrum because the
London is so annoying to deal with when
white doesn't take any risk and if black
tries to get a little too aggressive you
can get punished very swiftly very very
swiftly yeah so
um like Bishop C6 like you see like ding
is trying to be edgy you know like
Bishop like what is he doing right what
is this bishop C6 90s I'm like what is
he what is this but he's just trying to
he's trying to actually create a fight
but the hell's not fighting he's just
doing what he wants
New Hall isn't biting and just look at
how solid White's position is I could
stare at this for ages as much as I've
bad mouth the London on my stream most
of it is playful the London is a
tremendously sound opening it's an
opening that's so difficult to crack and
it's the perfect thing to play when
you're up by one in a match let alone
the fact that nehal plays it uh most of
the time it's one of his main weapons
and he very much plays it for a win but
the position is still undefined Levy we
could get an end game we could get a
trade of the night for the bishop we
could get a trade of Knight for night
it's there's a lot of tension in the
center and I'm very curious
who is actually going to be the one uh
who dictates the transformation will it
be white you know taking the queen or
will it be black trading right now both
sides keeping the tension Rook fc8 is a
very interesting move basically saying
the case you know there's a really
fascinating sacrifice here which is
absolute garbage but it's Knight takes
F7 like that is a move that you could
play in a Blitz game it obviously just
loses immediately because it doesn't get
you any anywhere anything resembling an
attack but
um you know what I mean though right
like it looks appetizing but there's
just nothing there um I was thinking
about that it's the first thing that
came to my mind it's just like an
instinct the moment The Rook leaves f8
yeah you're like oh I can sack and win
the pot on E6 but you have no attack so
Rook fd1 yeah both players are basically
saying this game is going to be played
on the queen side and in the center
nobody's going okay
great yeah
oh Bishop
immediately H3
yep always a good move Bishop can go to
H2 also white can start an attack with
G4 at a random moment and Black's kind
of like wait what we're attacking each
other notice how the Queens have had a
staring contest the entire game that's
probably confusing people but neither
side wants to take and damage the other
structure uh because in chess we have I
something I like to call kind of like
superseding Concepts you say oh double
pawns I'm so smart but actually opening
your opponent's Rook is worse so the
double pawns are outweighed by the fact
that the Rook gets super open uh and
that's why the queens were just staring
at each other
yeah that's a great point and you know
it's just so important to realize that
in such positions peace activity
outweighs these cosmetic deficiencies in
your structure so we might see the queen
staring at each other for another 10
moves I mean totally not unlikely
another question ding has to answer will
he play C4 I think now actually might be
a decent time to push C4 move the queen
out of B6 at last and then classic
minority attack insofar as the London
has Kryptonite it is I think this uh
pawn attack where black plays C4 pushes
the beep onto B4 and starts loading up
the pressure on White's uh integral
structurally integral C3 Point yeah and
actually it now starts becoming a
question of did nihal sort of
get a little bit lazy with all of this
right like he suddenly black has a plan
does white
yeah lazy is a great word to describe
this 95 to every why did he drop the
night back I think he was worried about
the prospect of black sending him away
with F6 and controlling some of the
center squares while he's at it but for
ding I think it's important to step on
the gas bill right now I actually really
feel strongly that C4 is the way to go
here
yeah this looks amazing by the way this
is set up by black Bishop E7 Bishop E8 I
wonder if ding
I I almost feel like it did he really
make this up in this game or has he seen
this somewhere because
I feel like these guys do so much
research right and I feel like maybe in
some of his analysis of London with the
computer he sort of went oh wow there's
this interesting idea to kind of like
keep the tension rook fc8 and then put
the Bishops like this uh and he puts his
Knight on D6 right you have this like
strong Center Knight and the pawns are
going next
by the way uh
what happened I stopped hearing you
there for a second lady oh that's okay I
think I think most of the most of the
chat wishes that they had that privilege
um so yeah let's uh uh we can um have
nepo and rajapov drawn their game or
what what's happening not yet yeah let's
pull up that game because I'm worried
about nepo I'm I'm just worried that
he's in that unsettled frame of mind
where you can screw up any position
okay this is early on the board guess
what nepo offered a draw and Timur
ajabov just declined it the plot
thickens oh my goodness Timur is just
straight up trying to beat him with
white
and yeah I mean black is a move behind
in this game it feels like
yeah guess what White's not losing this
game the structures imagine it's not
like Timor is oh you know I need to take
this draw because if I don't I'm going
to screw up I'm of he's thinking I'm a
four minutes on the clock my opponent is
clearly in a psychologically bad State
this is my chance to put this match to
bed with a win in this game so yeah why
not push for a couple more moves and if
black plays Rook A8 which looks
Supernatural because if you trade the
Rooks it's just going to be a draw why
does Knight E5 check and that poses a
whole new set of problems oh I actually
didn't see that let me let's pull up an
analysis board here rookie 95 check you
say what's the problem but the problem
is that you lose the bishop on B4 it's
not only why it's got the bishop air
pressure on the B file
Rook B3 this is very much unpalatable
for black
yeah this looks terrible and I mean Rook
A8 looks like it just makes a draw you
just trade Rooks nobody can play nobody
can win that and you're not winning the
same four pawns on the same side of the
board
but you can win this this is absolutely
winnable and I think for a job of
declined the draw after like uh one of
the most recent moves I think it was
King D7
um but uh yeah yeah I uh
I mean this is for job of wins this game
that's that is a statement answer me
this let's go back to the live position
here when was the last time Jana
palmistry was down
five and a half minutes on the clock
it's even just hard to say in one breath
janapanishi down five and a half minutes
yeah he's having a he's he's having a
bad day and it's combined with her job
of having a great one like it this
happens right you have a guy who who
can't get started with a guy that just I
don't know had a good breakfast all
right he's drinking I don't know I don't
know what he's he's drinking the Paula
Costa secret juice all right uh I I
don't know he just he's got a he's got
everything kind of firing for him on all
cylinders right now and uh he's got a
bright blue shirt it's one of my
favorite colors everything's sort of
going well yeah young yeah don't you
like light blue
a little bit wrinkled but we're not
going to talk about that that's okay I'm
honestly I'm dude I'm so bad at that
like you know that a close stay there
for two weeks
yeah I get my clothes out of the dryer
like I don't even put them in the bin I
don't fold them I'm so bad at that stuff
man not that anybody has to know that
but um
I don't know I'm talking about this
uh but listen we at least we've watched
them
you know yeah there's no wash our
clothes yeah oh yeah no I never go you
know even a week without doing laundry
no no no God forbid
never go a day I watched I watched the
clothes just you know every day every
day yeah the moment that one shirt
becomes dirty I run a cycle yeah this is
what this game has made us commentate on
can we check if ding has started an
attack on nihal how about that it's kind
of bad online conversation about laundry
is more interesting than the position
all right listen if you blame us look at
the position we got like a one minute
delay between chat and our voices and
you already know someone listen we get
everything we get complaints of we're
going too fast beginners can't follow we
get we're going to to do slow for
beginners experienced chess fans can't
follow next thing we're gonna oh we
deflecting the conversation away from
the chessboard I mean it it's you know
it's total symmetry like what do you
want that's why I'm trying to go here
daily Wren is about to attack the he's
about to attack a child how about that
for a headline
yeah that's uh that's pretty accurate
and he is reared and ready to go on the
queen side all of his pieces staring at
the right spots on the board the Evo bar
though isn't quite buying it it's still
giving an edge for white I maintained
that Ding probably should have played C4
earlier but is D takes E5 a dangerous
Prospect is white actually entertaining
that possibility it's not every day in
the London Levy that you give up this D4
Pawn that's something you always do with
a heavy heart and it's something that
you often accompany by pushing E4
yeah DC
um oh goodness I got so excited too you
can't say without coughing I know I'm
just so pumped about the center Pawn
break yeah dc5 is one of these moves
where if black has to recapture with a
piece that can be a Target then it's
good for white and that oftentimes
happens if you have to take with a queen
or a rook if a knight for black lands on
C5 it's bad for white generally but but
oh that's if okay
well that's setting up maybe dc5 and
some various b4s but uh actually not
even not really because but it's setting
up DC yeah exactly yeah I don't know
um I don't know that's probably the plan
right DC E4 try to blow the center open
or take on D6 and then E4
something like that
yeah the way I describe knee-hole's play
and this game is casual and that's not
necessarily a bad thing like I don't
think he's trying to involve himself too
deeply with variations what I think he's
telling himself is okay in most of these
positions there's gonna be three or four
moves that are going to be approximately
equivalent to each other I'm not going
to get too low on time and I'm going to
choose one of them intuitively I think
the strategy has worked pretty decently
ding has decided to trade on D4 and I've
always enjoyed these types of structures
for what I don't know about you
yeah this is a exchange Karo Khan Pawn
structure with one of the strangest it's
like it's like basically the players
started the game E4 C6 D4 D5 takes takes
and then said remove your back rank of
pieces and put them wherever you want
because that is sort of what happens in
the London if black ever takes on D4
white takes with the E Pawn and in this
case I am inclined to agree I really
like the attacking chances that white
gets over to that King side especially
the way dinga set up his pieces like the
Knight on D6 the Bishops on e78 but he's
basically saying you got nothing nothing
here yeah you beat me last game but
that's yeah that's in the past you have
no you have nothing here and I'm going
to attack you with my minority of Pawns
my DBA versus your ABCD B5 is on the way
B4 is on the way
um I say B4 twice or I say B5 B4 anyway
regardless that's what's coming and uh I
think ding has good winning chances
yeah he's done what he has to do right
he's kept pieces on the board he's kept
the structure a little bit imbalanced
he's kept a two-minute advantage on the
clock but eventually push is going to
have to come to shove and nihal is
trying to prevent that from happening A5
a classic move and these positions
discouraging black from pushing the beep
on that will only lead to more
weaknesses after on Passat raw back of
A5 is that it does yield the B5 square
is that square particularly noteworthy
is it a worthy Square to position a
piece things certainly think so Bishop
B5 is on the board yeah Bishop B5 is on
the board
um
I saw a comment that said Nepal
blundered I don't know if that's reality
generally we would be spammed with that
if it happened no he did he's down upon
we got to switch to that game ASAP
that's crazy John the palmistry is
having a meltdown in this match he
hasn't lost his game just yet but he is
on the cusp of doing just that
oh my goodness look at this
let's rewind a little bit in this
position he played Rook A8 Levy
and you can't keep both of these things
defended at the same time you got to
lose the pawn
and he's down to two minutes and 50
seconds he's down six minutes on the
clock oh my gosh holy smokes this is a
blowout
yeah I'm like uh I mean I'm just
completely shocked
he's got pretty serious strong chances
though because the pawns are all on one
side of the board
yeah what is the best okay the best case
scenario for black is obviously opposite
colored Bishop end game from here right
you need the opposite color Maps uh is
that realistic no
um is it easier or harder to draw an
endgame down a pawn when it's nights or
when it's Bishops
um it's a really good question I would
probably prefer
I don't know if I'd prefer both pairs of
Bishops to be gone or if I'd prefer one
pair of Bishops and one pair of nice
it's hard to say I think white would
prefer all the pieces on the board for
as long as possible maybe F3 E4 should
be considered maybe bring the king to E3
you're gonna see teamwork kind of slowly
accumulating the pressure and trying to
avoid unnecessary
Maybe
see this is what I have a hard time
understanding which pieces you want to
trade these are very high level
considerations
I know one thing Knight G6 is a great
boat that's a it's a really nice move
and as much and white is gonna have to
come forward that's the only way White's
gonna be able to win this game boy it's
gonna have to walk down the black
position and
remove the pieces from their Defender
defending squares and
slowly slowly prying apart the defenses
and black has a really tough structure
to defend because G7 is weak and E6 is
really weak
and yeah
yeah this is less than two minutes two
minutes on the clock nepo not used to
being in time pressure not used to being
a pawn down and one point down in the
match
with his back against the wall this is
crazy
Yep this is crazy
uh yeah the time is flipped I think the
time got flipped I don't know I don't
know what happened but yeah rajabov did
not just calmly get to the two minute
spot um
uh sometimes that happens
um
anyway
as you can see there it's Yan who has
two minutes and it's Yan who is
defending the position
uh we got chances
he doesn't tilt
yeah he has chances because again uh for
the for the manyth time that I can use
that word black is worse but uh you know
White's gotta go forward white has the
chance to make the mistake or the
inaccuracy
yeah the position's not going to win
itself the problem the white faces is
that every trait of Hans tears a little
bit out of White's heart and if three
pairs of puns are traded black could
even give a minor piece for the last
remaining Pawn so in order to win white
basically will have to win another Pawn
at some point and nepo's not just giving
it away easily you can see he brings his
King to E7 okay preferably you don't
want to miss a fork so Timur is going to
try to keep finagling keep maneuvering
his pieces and I think he's going to try
to go after this E6 Pawn one way or the
other
yeah and if he plays a move like Knight
C5 does Jan want the trade there
I don't think so right no I don't think
he wants the bishop error to give white
the bishop there yeah cause that's going
to be real tough to defend against the
Bishops just stare you down for the rest
of the game
um so Knight C5 Bishop F7 I guess is his
attention
uh-huh yeah I mean stubborn Defender
H4 okay classic you know end game moves
by Timor I think we're gonna see the F2
and he's gonna try to milk black squawk
down to a minute that's when you know
the real stuff hits the fan because
that's when you just don't have time to
react to unexpected stimuli in the
position
yeah it's a great way of putting it yeah
you're you're on high alert at that
point and one move by your opponent that
you did not expect and you're just kind
of like and then you make a mistake I
mean last game young blundered kind of
this back rank
deflection tactic
um yeah he kind of
okay so now yeah King F2 G4 G5
yeah G4 G5 is probably the only pair of
Pawns it is worth trading because
otherwise how are you actually going to
knock any of black Pieces away from
their posts
you know one and a half minutes for an
apple even less
well it's so hard for young because he
has nothing he just basically sits and
waits and he is hoping that white messes
up
that's really what he's hoping for and
see Morgan you know stay on cruise
control for miles and miles right he is
under no obligation to make any
commitments if he wants to play 30 moves
and torture young he can do that John is
taking another big chunk of time and
that's what he was thinking about big
decision there Levy to proactively push
the pawn to G5
it's a very tough spot now here does
what do we think about like do we want
to take on G5 and leave the pawn there
okay well that answers that question yep
I have a good move you didn't want to go
G4 because of Bishop G5 with an eternal
pin against the Knight
yep now black is a move away from
getting the bishop back either with D6
or Bishop B2
I think Jan is doing a phenomenal job so
far
hey is three pieces versus two winning
I was actually one I was gonna ask you
that question
I had an end game like that once and I I
managed to win but it took like 150
moves but I think I also had two Bishops
versus like a knight which helped
uh whereas you know you gotta now think
if white has two Bishops in a knight and
black has two pieces black probably
wants two Bishops right maybe black
wants a knight I don't know
I think so too I think black probably
wants well the ideal is like bishop and
Knight against Bishop as well as bishop
and Knight against Knight is a pretty
easy draw but the addition of a third
minor piece the defensive task obviously
becomes a lot harder does it become
insurmountable
I don't quite know yeah I don't it's
it's prop it's I don't know I want to
say it's probably a draw but the
computer would show
nappos staying on high alert the threat
there was E5 knocking the Knight away
from H7
so for the time being Jan he keeps a
minute on his clock he keeps his
position intact
yeah you also have the other game but
I don't know
this one is good this one may end
man uh relatively soon
yup and I'm keeping an eye on the other
on the other game in case the position
explodes the position there is still
pretty closed so we'll take you there as
soon as there's concrete action
right now we're watching nepo struggle
in time pressure he needs to hold the
draw here a loss in this game puts him
down 2-0 and basically ends the match
yes Bishop C1
uh does rajaba go for a trade of pieces
I mean you almost don't want to because
your opponent has 40 seconds
you can't well I guess you can go King
F6
E5 King G7 whoa
hanging by a thread
well
so close
96 Bishop C6 doesn't actually seem to
give all that much
great defending by Yan I know I'm like
trying to find a way to poke a hole in
the defense but I can't
and now the time Advantage is down to
four minutes
you know it sounds still like a line is
a lot but
you can imagine spending you know two
three minutes trying to figure out a way
as you said to poke a hole and if this
gets down to a Time scramble I think
nepo is going to hold um
yeah agreed we're we are definitely far
away from that though I feel like I feel
like we may get a break potentially from
this game just because Jan I mean Timur
is going to spend a few minutes here
trying to find some way in you can only
Shuffle so many times we've kind of
gotten to that point where white has
made as much progress as possible oh
maybe not kingy two yeah that is another
method run your king all around to the
edge of the board
yeah King C1 there will be Bishop A4
check no pasta Ron I mean
it is Art even to Envision how white
makes progress maybe at some point to
more pushes G3 but that just creates
another liability and you're gonna have
to keep your king or your Bishop stuck
defending that pawn
I don't know I think I think uh nepo is
pretty close to holding his own here
yep
I agree shall we switch to the other
game for a brief moment just for a
change of scenery
huh yeah let's do it
okay and this seems to be going pretty
well for the Chinese number one he's got
a Time advantage
and he has made serious progress
inducing weaknesses on the queen side of
your white
yeah it really feels like nehala has
sort of floated through this game
like he just he hasn't been able to come
up with a concrete plan and ding on the
other hand is very clearly coming up
with a concrete plan and nehal is
uncomfortable he's down three minutes
I was gonna say this is ding's greatest
asset as a chess player I think
the ability to overcome
and he might have that skill better than
anybody I mean of course
gonna say Magnus probably just in every
conversation but ding is just so good at
like he will have a bad first game that
doesn't mean anything he will come back
so strong in the next one and all the
others after
yeah he's got that incredibly upbeat
quality I just feel like he focuses on
the positive
and he plays the same way every game
which is such a an important recipe for
success in in these match formats these
knockout tournaments you know you don't
want to do anything crazy even if you're
in trouble in the match you just want to
play the way that you normally play
and
being doing pretty well but nihal he's
not just going to
you know float away and die Knight F4 is
a clear sign Levy that he still has
blood on his mind Knight takes H5 is a
huge threat followed by Queen G5 and
that's actually just check maybe
blundered it oh
he blundered it
oh my goodness
and White's got at least a Perpetual
there
what the heck
oh my goodness thing is devastated
is real
ding is devastated
I think Nicole might actually take the
draw though
why would he do that
but what okay so let's open an ALICE
board real fast yeah the point is that
GH gets mated check
check and mate
but instead ding doesn't take the Knight
he goes King H7 and he says what else do
you have other than repetition well
you've got a minute on the clock I think
nihal's not gonna risk it I think he's
going Knight F6 and taking
wow
for a job of one apparently against
yanyupo machine in the meantime what
what is happening oh he trapped his
Bishop we gotta go back to that game now
this is crazy Bishop
oh okay so we saw this uh-huh Bishop H5
was the blunder you seal off this
passageway you see love this passageway
and the Knight seals off the B2 and A3
squares Bishop oh that's crazy and it's
because he had no time he had 13 seconds
Holy Cannoli and exactly it's the time
pressure that ultimately got him and in
the meantime's going for the win
wow
we gotta switch back with 26 seconds on
his clock and ice in his way in his
veins in his wings his wings
oh that is that is that is oh my
goodness I slipped off my chair and
alsarin is playing for a win with 20
seconds on the clock I can't believe
this and you know why because he knows
that he has to draw in his pocket this
Knight F6 repetition
65. holy smokes
wait but there's ed4 Queen E7 27 no it's
easy
or this this is also good oh and it's
just made
no this is just absolute Collapse by
ding
King G8 maybe keeps some hopes alive
oh my gosh ding is absolutely devastated
I mean he just after a blunder after
allowing Knight takes H5 I just think he
wasn't the same
yeah yeah he's uh I mean he's he's
stunned he's in complete disbelief
blundering Knight takes H5
I'm a little bit surprised that nihal
didn't in Knight takes D5 though that
ended the game immediately
yeah but okay so does Knight G4
this is just this is this is shocking
what a day
underdogs are are just dominating today
but
up six protected it's not Checkmate just
yet I want to see a couple more accurate
moves by knee Hall in order to actually
win this game yeah I agree let's not
forget he has 20 seconds now this we are
about to find out if if all that hype is
real the 3160 Blitz rating the also
nearly getting a 50 score against Magnus
and Blitz like
I mean nihal is a is top four on the
leaderboard of chess.com let's see if
it's for a reason if you give him any
bonus time it's like a little you know
jet pack uh for him to to fly across to
the finish line and
ding has to find a way to defend this
and if nehal finds all the accurate
moves that's that's sort of it oh I just
realized that after Bishop E7 there's
simply Rook C2
I mean at a minimum and you Force black
to give the queen away because the Rook
on seat is undefended that's why uh ding
is actually not moving
yeah because he realizes Rook C2 is
there him
so Bishop C5 Bishop yeah that's it Rook
C2 rookie two ends it
and it's not the only move you can
probably play H5 and stuff
it's not even a question just Queen H6
and Knight F6 you you can actually give
up the E1 Rook with check yeah it
doesn't matter yep Knight F6 takes six
rookie one king G2 black resigns easy
clap Knight F6 is child's play for
knee-haul
that is oh that that is so sick
sensational
we've got 2-0 in both matches Levy if
you would have told me that I would have
staked in my life savings that it was
2-0 for nepo well 2-0 for ding
just um so it's the Checkmate on G7
Loren's King is checkmated this is
literally the least likely result that
we had about two minutes ago and nihal
sarin is now up two nothing dingley Ren
on the ropes it is now must win or that
is it he is knocked out of the chess.com
Global Championship presented by Brave
this is a astounding score line
I'm stunned
I I have no words I'm shocked and this
game seemed to be going Yang's way he
did everything he had to do he was
playing at a classic ding style closed
position making improvements getting the
hello on time Knight H3 to F4 takes H5
you just can't make these kinds of
blunders against the likes of nihal
siren I mean he's going to punish you a
million percent of the time
and let's not forget Timur a job of what
an absolute Beast just crazy the way
he's been beating nepo like he's nothing
Levy like he's you know not just one the
candidate isn't playing for a world
championship against dingley red the
other guy who's down 2-0 that's insane
both World Championship
contenders are down to nothing in their
head-to-head matchups this is
legitimately the most shocking day of
the chess.com Global Championship that
we have ever had I mean there have been
days with upsets there have been days
with back and forth matches after two
games in each of these matches these are
the most unpredicted scores hands down
guaranteed I think everybody is stunned
right now and the players who are down
to Zero have to win the next two games
they have to recover and they have a
couple of minutes to do that to win two
games and then to win Armageddon will
either of the players will Yana pamushi
or dingly Ren rise to the occasion if a
player is to rise to the occasion well
I'm putting my money that one of those
two is capable of doing it don't go
anywhere because in the other side of
this break the chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave returns
with both World Championship contenders
facing a 2-0 deficit we'll be right back
with game three
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we are witnessing Sensational
performances all around here at the
round of 16 in the chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave
International Master Levy Rosman you're
looking at the nepo Raj above card no
this is not a typo two ones 40 more he
leads with a score of 2-0 and NEPA will
have to mount the first 2-0 comeback in
the cgc thus far if he wants to stay in
this match
yeah uh why did you say International
Master Levy Rosman I feel like that's
when you call your parents by their full
name I was so caught off guard by that
oh that's okay that's okay
no no I'm I I'm still talking uh it's
all good yeah listen this is um if you
ask me after two rounds what I thought
the score would be uh I did not think it
was going to be 2-0 for either player
and if you told me hey it's going to be
2-0 well listen no disrespect whatsoever
but it's probably gonna go to the person
who was voted 96 likely to win this
match right by the community uh and
that's currently what's happening in
just totally the opposite direction so
uh it is taymor rajabov with a
two-nothing lead uh despite being voted
by four percent of the audience
to win this match and he is doing it in
literally the most dominant the Fashions
while nehal sarin voted for 17 percent
is also up two to nothing in his match
uh Donnie can you still hear me no
no all right well it's just me solo on
the air it's a worse nightmare situation
for the fans uh but I suppose we can
continue to move along
um and I could could probably discuss
the nehal versus ding match or pull up
the scoreboard for that one but that is
also a shocking turn of events a little
bit of a different story in that match
because in the first round nihal sort of
showed up and stamped his presence uh
but in the second game he was not
necessarily fighting back from a defeat
but he
oh you back
I can hear you now yeah I'm sorry I
don't have no idea what happened there
that's all right uh I was just
explaining to the audience how nihal
sarin got to his two-nothing lead in the
second game he was slightly worse
slightly unpleasant position but he
defended it and literally the moment
that uh Dania uh not not done I just
looked at you and I was so excited to
have you back uh you know
um but uh no the second that Ding made a
mistake I mean he was just pounced on
and it was um easy I mean anyhow you
know what I can't get over the fact that
he decided to go for a 26 seconds
can you can we just like stop on that
for a second four minutes for ding nehal
can take a draw you're up one and a half
half good result no we need three ice
water in his wings
and he all's uh ding's chances of coming
back in this match just waned
by a lot after losing that second game
just sensational
that was amazing uh and I think we have
the first few moves coming uh of uh of
the nepo versus rajab of matchup listen
uh we have absolutely nowhere to hide
yeah has to now win two games he has
looked
not only has he looked
just a bit disheveled he's also just
looked a bit unhappy and stressed out
throughout like the entire match and I I
don't know I'm not seeing uh I'm not
seeing a very
I don't know scary intimidating Young
no this is wildly uncharacteristic uh
given his recent performances he seems
discombobulated in the opening remember
that Bishop F4 in the first game he
seems slow
and just isn't playing with a whole lot
of confidence and
right now he's got a very clear
challenge ahead of him he's not thinking
I've got to win the next two games he's
thinking I've got to get a good position
out of the opening because he hasn't
managed to get even remotely the kind of
position he wanted in either of the
first two games so that's really step
one for him
yeah that second game he had a chance to
close the center and start scrapping it
was very clear that his mentality was
not to necessarily win with black and uh
he he like that's not his style his
style is not to defend a position of
dead symmetry maybe in the world
championship with 90 minutes on the
clock or whatever the heck the time
control is in the world champion
something but it's like two hours
for two minutes yeah 30 moves
yep yep yep
um and uh that's sort of the that's sort
of the the standing you know
um but Queen D6 and this is some sort of
line
these lines are very they all sort of
fuse together in my mind but I I think
um
I think this is some sort of like
Italian early D5 line I think Hikaru
legs these lines Levon likes these lines
with black very aggressive
um by the way B4 look looks like a peace
trap
wait isn't it
or what am I missing here
I don't know what am I missing what am I
missing BP for
um oh okay apparently okay I will
totally and unashamedly admit that I
just cheated but Knight C4 BC it does
win a piece but after Queen G6 DC black
has D4 back and I went in the piece back
that is just something you have to know
you're not going into this unless you
know this wow
wow that's pretty cute actually
yeah that's that's Savage you're just
looking like why is the bishop on C5 got
no squares ah it's because of this four
move tactical refutation okay cool yeah
yeah now what's interesting if we go
back to the live position this E5 move
it was all a rage I think a couple years
ago then it fell out of fashion now
everybody seems to be playing D6
automatically but Yasser has talked
about it on uh in his commentary before
how open day fashion is really
interesting openings don't always fall
out of favor simply because they're
better someone refuted them that's a
very common misconception openings often
fall out of favor because Magnus Carlson
decided to
you know play something different it
doesn't always mean the move was refuted
or is known to be bad
yeah it's just like fashion trends it's
just like that uh and by the way I've
been gotten a I I've been gotten oh my
goodness I got a an update
uh from our stats team uh actually from
I think Mr chesscom India himself uh and
he said that nobody
in this year's chess.com Global
championship
has made a comeback from two nothing
down to win the match we have seen
comebacks
but we have not seen a match one
once you go down to nothing
yeah that's
that says a lot
so if somebody can pull it off right now
uh that would be spectacular now this
name is not is a bit notorious right now
in the world of chess
uh but the most legendary two-nothing
comeback that I remember is uh from
Sergey kariak and he was down to nothing
in the world cup and he won two games
yep he beats Fiddler and then he played
for the world championship because of
that right I mean that was uh maybe he
played because he made it to the final
already but he won the World Cup after
going down to nothing so it's possible
it's not likely but it's possible listen
it's it's not five games it's not ten
games it's two games of Rapid you know
you think about the amount of games Jan
won in the candidates
you know it's it it is not an impossible
ask in principle the problem is just
that when you're down to zero that
generally means your opponent is in much
better form and that generally means
your opponent is playing with tremendous
confidence and for Timur it's just such
a luxurious feeling okay worse comes to
us disaster strikes hey I'm gonna get
white in the next game and a draw Still
wins me the match so if you're Timor in
this situation you can essentially play
with nothing to lose it's a great
feeling and every move that Jan is
playing he's like I can't allow this to
be a draw I can't allow this to be a
draw it's like an Armageddon game for
only one side yep
absolutely right by the way uh we have a
we have liftoff in the game between ding
Loren and nihal sarin
so if we can pull that up
that's a very tough situation for ding
nihal is playing a Queen's Gambit
accepted one of the most solid lines
here E6 A6 ding is gonna have to come up
with one of the 37 different setups here
for white okay chooses B3 yeah A3 B3
Knight D2 oh it's actually crazy it's
like A3 B3 Knight D2 Knight C3 Bishop D3
Bishop E2 Bishop B3 Queen E2 Rook D1 I
mean it's just so many setups it's I was
gonna say don't you leave Queen E2 out
there I know you have a anti-queeney to
bias that's unacceptable I know you got
like everything and uh yeah the top guys
they love digging around in the sandbox
for all of this I I never played this
system with black because I couldn't
possibly learn all of these lines uh I
would rather you know play some goofy
Gambit and Blitz
um no Queen's Gambit accepted is
extremely popular right now and I think
it's it's Black's newest attempt at uh
equalizing without much of an effort
this reminds me of this old game um I
think it was nepo against rajava it's
many many years ago at the chest.com
global Championship presented by
everybody remember that game presented
by Brave
yeah yeah I I don't I don't remember all
of the interesting commentators
um I I I think it was I don't I know
nariditsky was one of the two there was
some idiot with like a like a shirt made
of his curtains I don't know it was um
it was it was a fun game and you know
we're a job of uh rajaba I think got the
job done in that game
yeah I seem to vaguely remember that as
well man the years have really taken
their toll B6 by nihal kind of an
interesting moment here Levy I think the
vast majority of players would just
automatically play B5 but the drawback
of pushing B5 is that the b-pawn becomes
a Target it sticks out like a sore thumb
and very often you have to contend with
this nasty Pawn push to A4 carving out
the C4 Square four white side B6 is more
modest but it's also a more efficient uh
and more solid way to develop yep yes it
is and it doesn't allow white to get
that typical Queen side action white has
a microscopic pull in these positions uh
and uh
you know nihal so ding plays
and sits like a chess player like even
online he's got the thinking pose and
everything nihal plays like an anime
character charging up like a you know
like a superpower he sort of sits there
like head down just like
and just like charging up you know like
and he just sits so far away I don't
even know how he makes moves it's like
he makes moves telepathically all right
like how long is his arm to control the
mouse you know oh now he's getting a
little bit closer but uh yeah like I'm
saying some people when they play they
look super focused nihal looks like uh
he has to file last year's tax return
okay and he's late on it or something it
just looks so right I know
um anyway I got my CPA during the
commentary I don't know listen listen
though you're good you're good I'm not
trying to get anybody audited uh but uh
yeah it's just so fun to watch like
these players playing from their own
house because they they're all like in
suits and in shirts at the Olympiad and
so intense and then at home they're just
sort of like
I just sit back relax
and as we're talking knee Hall's built
up a two and a half minute advantage on
the clock that's how both of the first
two games started now the previous game
the situation flipped and he haul got
bow on the clock but you know in terms
of only needing a draw this is the best
start that you could have dreamed of
three minute time Advantage already a
position that you are comfortable with
I've seen Queen's Gambit accepted Romney
hall for years now
and man ding
he needs a rabbit out of the hat and he
needs it now
well he has to win a chess game I don't
know about pulling livestock out of a
hat but um yeah yeah he he definitely
does in fact need to do that and he has
to find a way out you see how stress
ding is it's because this is the
position okay like
you know last game white didn't have to
win he just sort of did in that rajab of
game versus nepo but in this game you
have to win it's very different when
you're up one nothing and when you're
down to nothing that is a three-point
turnaround okay so last game where Java
just sort of made moves and then ended
up winning the game but dingley Wren
must win he's trying to find the best
way forward like he's probably gonna
play Queen E2 you know he's gonna play
Rook fd1 Rook AC one
what
you run out of moves at some point like
you actually have to
do something create an attack somewhere
yeah do the same thing seven Rook C or
d8 I think we might see a very
symmetrical position here how is then
going to unbalance this position well
that remains to be seen I'd like to
check into the other game because I
think just looking at the little
snapshot
I think the teamwork job of might have
got himself into a bit of trouble here
maybe more than a bit of trouble so got
an end game the Queens are off the board
sounds like good news for the side that
needs to make a draw well you actually
look at the position it ain't good news
the knights jumping into C5 Levy this is
the flat out double attack 96 and Knight
takes B7 lack's position is
in Ruins here this whole D5 experiment
by Timur I think I'm beginning to see
why it fell out of fashion
I know seriously something very strange
happened in this game I mean the level
shift just totally reversed itself Jan
is now up three minutes Yana has a
dominant position and Jan has all of the
Dynamics in his favor if only this could
have been game one for him right it's a
shame that he suddenly just down to
nothing but
we still have two games to go crazier
things have happened and yeah he looks
just completely poised to begin his
comeback
he really does let's pull up an analysis
board just to indicate the extent uh to
which Black's position is terrible So
currently the bishop is hanging after
Bishop takes G3 FG I think the only way
to defend against both threats is Rook
V8 but that's it's not the end of the
story I mean why can like a move like D4
just look at the extent of White's
dominance Knight on C5 Levy the Rooks
are perfectly positioned it's not
because of one specific reason that
black is in trouble it's just my
position sucks I don't know of a more
scientific way to put it
I completely agree with you and black
has no moves and also this is just not
something you ever want to do like if
the options are at this position not
down upon or way more active but down
upon you're going to choose the one
that's down upon but uh that means
you're down a pawn just in case anyone's
not clear about the math
yeah like even you know this is
preferred because you see rajabov is
probably going to sacrifice B7 it's just
I don't know I don't know how he's gonna
do it maybe he won't but if he tries to
defend everything in his position then
um yeah I mean this is yeah like say
there you go
yeah but you've sacked B7 tonight's just
gonna dip back to C5 and I died I know
man I have to be seven punch I know you
just have the same position but now
you're a pawn down oh he plays Rook B8
right let's go for this line yes he's
trying to keep all his spawns intact
yep
but nepo the great thing about a
position like this with white is that
why doesn't know her you can play D4 you
can bring your king up you can basically
do what Tim Moore was doing to you in
the previous game when he was up upon
you know now you can give a taste of to
give him a taste of his own medicine
yeah I feel like uh this is going to be
a repeat of one of the pre D forces
exactly the position that you put on the
board and this just looks completely
miserable does black even have a move oh
that's what he's got to try Knight A5
Knight C4 rookie seven though
just give it up what do you need the
bishop forces rookie seven
I'll take the bishop and I think you're
right I think rajaba is gonna have to
strategically to try to sack
probably the B7 pawn and try to get the
Rook off of the seventh rank I don't
know how he's gonna do that though yep
me neither
no he decides to keep the bishop ready
man
I don't even know if it's greedy he's
not even keeping any material he's just
well can't you play like B3 what is the
idea here
rookie seven anyway uh the Knight D5 the
95.
okay but you could play C4 C4 and nepo a
removing C4 yeah
no this is just getting worse and worse
96 the position I don't use this phrase
lightly I think it's an overused phrase
by commentators the position basically
plays itself Oh I thought you were gonna
say it might be an accurate yourself
right I thought I thought you were gonna
say it speaks for itself but
and that's an underused phrase
yeah well it does speak for itself and
it does play itself you notice they'll
have like five moves by white made in
seconds
yep and this is more like the nepo that
we're used to seeing we're used to
seeing and also yeah this is this is his
style of game downhill powering through
just beast mode it sort of feels like
right
and it just you know I think a lot of
his problems in the first two games had
to do with his opening choice I don't
want to over analyze this over
psychologize but I think Netflix just
got so fed up with the position that he
got in game one he's like I had the
white pieces could have played a Catalan
could have played one E4 instead I
basically got a lost position out of the
opening it feels like only now he's
beginning to forgive himself and play
the kind of Chess that we're used to see
him playing
is it too late maybe not I mean it's not
just this game he puts himself in a
pretty good position yeah it's not too
late for this game is it too late to win
with black it very well could be I think
that that that game that he lost with
uh with black will probably hurt more
than the game that he that she lost with
white in the first one because that that
last game was just completely
symmetrical right and
yeah he'll definitely be upset that's an
interesting perspective
that that the previous game really hurt
him but hey still has work to do on the
board Timur a job of is is not just
going to you know fold over and die oh
no not I and he does decide to sack upon
unfortunately
the relief seems very short-lived C6
maybe try to get the Knight back to D7
could you see a Universe where teamwork
saves this game
oh that would be so annoying
that would be so annoying uh Jan just
deserves a win no I know so some chess
purists in the chat gonna be like ah
nobody deserves a win but like it's just
such a great position with white like
Jan just put it away just pretend you're
playing me deserves a win
yeah but like just I keep saying if they
were playing me in title Tuesday for
example the game would have been over
like 10 moves ago you know what I'm
saying just put it away we all want to
uh you know we all want to see a game
four we don't want to see anybody go
home in three games
I'm gonna make a very bold prediction no
stop it
I think two more is going to save this
come on stop it I don't know I'm just
getting a feeling
Knight D6
8 rookie I I can't go rookie six though
but hey on the board
97 97 forces The Rook to the corner
the thing is like optically White's
tandem is so much stronger but what is
it going to attack the one silver lining
for black hair literally the only one is
that there are no remaining Targets in
Black's position so in order to win this
game why it's either gonna have to like
get a rook to E8 which is hard or create
a past one but there's a timing issue
it's not easy to choose the proper
moment to play B5
yeah and if you play C5 you say haha you
can't put your knight on D6 but then
your opponent says okay I'm gonna put my
net on D5 which is probably way better
jokes on you
yeah that Knight is I don't know though
you you could play C5 97 Knight C4
Knight D5 Knight D6 you can do this or
Knight A5 oh Knight A5 looks really good
actually
wait wait repeat that phrase
C5 okay 97 94.
Knight C4 Knight D5 Knight A5
attack
attack I have to play Rook V8 review
none of those errors were accurately
drawn
and you still can't win the damn pawns
it's absurd
why get the Rooks of the seventh
okay nepo has made a move let's go back
to live position and see what he has
decided Rook F4 and he has played C5 and
he's done it at a moment when black he's
maximized the the time that it takes for
black to get that night around 55.
yup Knight B5 so now black okay so he's
forcing 93
maybe oh man
and then maybe next to d8
what is he on trying to do here
I think A4 is a very careless move it
sends the Knight where it wants to go
and you know what I think he missed I
think he forgot Knight C3 was a thing I
think he thought the Knight has to go
back to C7 yeah you play Rook F7
everything's in order but no it's a
little bit more complicated yeah but
I think it's still really good for white
like I think losing D4 for B7 is still a
massive Plus for white because you can
remove the knight from D4 right
and you can always try to win C6 and A7
but it's getting sharp which I I don't
know who that benefits but
counter plays see what I'm saying though
I see what you're saying yeah I think he
also just missed Knight C3 with Knight
E2 it's just not what you were expecting
he definitely missed it you can tell
because he's taking a long time and
there's also the psychological component
you know nepo's already annoyed at
himself he's already on edge about the
weight he's playing all it takes is one
little seed of doubt and all of a sudden
the situation it's almost out of control
but I like Rook F7 I think he's still on
the right track and if he can get some
more you know down below two minutes
his chances of winning are still very
very but hey I made my prediction I'm
gonna stick
yeah so now King F2 or King G2
okay there's all right question answered
rookie eight and rookie two Black's
getting counter play oh my goodness oh
man wait what was did he what did he
have to play instead of why did the evil
go were you supposed to not move the
thing after Knight E2 apparently the
move is King G2
Knight takes D4 Rook takes B7 oh and now
there's Knight F3 and the crazy thing
with the King on F2 there's Rook f8
hitting the Knight here you say but
rookie two wins the night no it doesn't
because the game drops back to F1 making
contact with the Rook
that is yeah crazy level of subtlety I
had a I had a feeling yeah I was gonna I
had a feeling going to F2 was maybe bad
because the King was in the open but
it also makes sense because you want to
get the king involved in the end game
you don't want the king stuck on the G
file and
this is insane as rajava actually going
to save this position that's so wild
he's basically destroying this I mean
Knight takes B3 is now an Unstoppable
threat Levy try that on for size
if you move the Knight away from C4 you
lose C5 White's gonna White's Queen side
is suddenly getting pulverized
I can't believe this is nuts he's
actually gonna make a comeback
it's back to normal and how quick ly did
he do that I mean it five moves ago
white was in the driver's seat black
didn't even have a car
now she quite someone ubering everywhere
Black's got a Ferrari
I know this is just incredible wow
what a crazy turn of events we still
have the other game of course but
this is really the game that's on
everyone's Minds right now I think
yeah this is uh
this is wild wow
um yeah it's a great position in the
meantime
nihal has a great position
I believe he does oh okay I don't know
where we want to go we got a rook and
Knight end game here to decide the match
we got nihow with a better position
that's great are we actually going to be
out here in six games
we very well might the way things are
going right now I still think that Tim
Moore has a lot of work to do John in
his best days knows how to complicate
these types of positions so he is going
to fight to the last drop of blood net
A5 is a clear indicator of that he
doesn't want to give away any more pawns
than necessary on the queen side and
Levy the most important thing of force
is for white to keep the past upon on A4
and it will become passed after white
takes on A7 on the next move
yeah the key here for black is the draw
along the second rank with Knight F3 and
some Perpetual but it doesn't quite
exist uh let's let Timor think let's go
check in on nihal very briefly
and you told me he has a great position
uh
wow
holy smoke this is
he's up three minutes and he's better
with black
and he's not just better he's forcing a
queen trade he's dominating in the
center look at the way he's positioned
his pieces ding hasn't even finished his
Queen side development
yeah this is incredible I think
black should just trade Queen's play
Rook d8 and claim that I'm never going
to lose that in a million years
Nicole thinks that
uh oh I'm I'm sorry I thought he just I
thought he just played a move because
you highlighted a square uh no he's just
convincingly better it's like no
questions asked yeah I mean you can
trade queens and play to not lose you
can probably do even more than that I
wonder if he already has some tactic
like Queen D1 and Knight C2 but yeah I
mean I'm looking at different ways for
him to start
attacking and
yeah these young players yeah they're
not just gonna grovel for a try I think
nehal is seriously considering going for
3-0 with Queen C7 and Rook da whites
Queen is feeling mighty claustrophobic
there surrounded by you know its own end
in by its own pieces
so big decision here for nehal I think
Queen takes D1 is the move you play if
you're like you know want to make that
professional draw
after Queen C7 I don't see him losing
that game either
oh this is what a day for any Hall what
a what a day we've got to start
respecting him as uh the future
uh coming out of India for for speed
chess for sure he is not yet 2700
classical but
I really feel like he just yeah he just
doesn't play enough and he probably will
be
I totally agree with that idea I think
he
man
I know this is rapid this is a different
animal that is true
but you don't just accidentally stumble
into what very well could be a 3-0 win
against the world championship you just
you just don't it's it just doesn't
happen by accident
and I've been saying that Niha will be
2700 for a while now I stand by that I
think he's going to be a force to be
reckoned with in the years to come yeah
I mean still has work to do in this game
yeah he has work to do in this game and
in this match but by the way him not
being 2700 really doesn't mean a whole
lot considering he's at basically his
highest rating ever in classical so he's
never been at a higher rating it's like
two points away from his Peak so give
him a few classical tournaments over the
board and I think he'll be just fine
yeah I mean listen you made a great
Point earlier about
um
the difference in rating means means a
lot less these days than it did in the
in the past you know 2600 speeding 27.50
you barely bat an eye a Wonder Liang
crushes levonaronian the U.S
Championship it's a great game but
you're not as surprised as you would be
let's say 10 years ago I mean just
echoing your plan from earlier
you know it's the wild west out there
and these top GMS better watch out
because the Young Guns are coming
yeah a new one is emerging every day and
the cream of the crop of the junior
players just keeps getting better and
better and once these clashes actually
happen the young guys are winning
they're just straight up winning
yeah we are seeing here
and they're no longer afraid they're no
longer making decisions because oh my
opponent is 2800 so he must have seen
this in that line they are trusting
themselves and that I think is the
single scariest transformation that's
happened to these players
that's incredible to see how does nihal
actually put this away though why is he
so much better what does he have some
Knight C2
well I think he lost a little bit of his
Advantage by trading Queens but he knew
that and that's why he invested so much
time I think the idea Knight c294
you can also Park the night back on D5
if you want to just play A5
so
I can
take it easy here
Yeah well black can take it easy ding
the Run cannot take it easy everyone's
gotta go
yeah I don't know how he's if you give
like five moves how does white even
produce
I mean
radio silence
I
I don't know I really don't know you
probably have to try to get like a
knight versus Bishop end game like
Knight versus darkscore Bishop but
Daniel also doesn't know he's leaving
I'm leaving I'm closing my blinds
funny
oh yeah
yeah so Sunny is not good are those
salmon shorts
they are no they're red and
the backlight
I'm
steps in life
yeah wow that's uh you you salmon shorts
kind of guy you got you got the sure mic
is that the mic that you have
uh yes but I'm not totally sure is it
the Shure sm7b with like the did you
miss my butt it is indeed
oh I did miss your pun yes so we gotta
commentate more I know you you're always
hitting Robert Hess with puns I didn't I
didn't that's that's the level of
intellect of those fun
is really I mean they're hard to spot
yeah they're tough they're layered
there's a lot of kind of you know
underlying uh
I can't even think of a good word to
follow up there but um yeah but speaking
of which I look at dingler and ding
Loren is going back to the first rank to
figure out what's next in the position
yeah all fair I mean listen he's
incredibly level-headed but he must be
feeling nervous right now Toronto is
literally on the line he's going to
Canada with a 200 000 first prize if he
draws this game how can you not be
feeling at least a little bit of jitters
a little butterflies in your stomach
um yeah
you know if going to Canada might make
you more nervous than potentially
winning two hundred thousand dollars
okay it's Canada what the hell are you
even doing there uh no not Hamilton
Wilds land yeah yeah it's just moose
just walking on the streets in Canada
you know just maple syrup spilled all
over the place I don't know
I um I was once in Edmonton Canada and
let me tell you that
that was the only time in my life I hope
I ever go to Edmonton Canada but the
other places are not bad
now I was like I'm gonna go Google some
flights after this yeah
[Music]
all right do some Airlines well A5 is
another great move it protects the night
with upon taking the load off of the
bishop why so that the bishop can move
to D4 and knock off this E5 Pawn if you
can get ding to play out for it that's
another major weakness that's more
vulnerable squares and more prospects
for Black Knight
yeah
yeah this is this is not looking great
uh by the way the job of us 40 seconds
let's go let's go check in on that
matchup
let's check it out I think Timor might
have lost his grip on the position
[Music]
all right 20 seconds there we go napo's
still up a pawn
the grip has certainly been lost let's
put it this way I wonder if Rook D2
Knight B3 rook d8 and Rook B8
is winning or not okay
okay he's just gonna push he's pushing
that he's his entire claim is staked on
this Pawn how is him we're going to stop
it it's going to play Knight B5
no I mean how do you defend this with 16
seconds you probably don't like B6
yeah Knight B6 or but now Knight B5 I
think this is the last stand for two
more A7 would be a terrible blunder here
but never look at him playing fast
yeah yeah yeah Evan no not over
that is a depressing move to have to
make but respectable lest we forget
material is equal
King E3 King D4 King C5 just let the
king go do it with his bare hands
whatever you do don't walk into King f8
Knight D7 black I think wants to play
the playroom then start walking with his
own King
don't go King f8
yeah he won't he won't uh King D4 Rook
D5
and then E4 no I I know but oh and then
Knight C6 is a threat
yep so two more trying to save time
rookie two by nepo so we're rookie five
I thought Rook A5 there was a big chance
to win the potty place now 97 Knight B8
or Knight C5 okay Rook A1 Maybe
or Rook A3
no he's trying to knock this
construction is very fragile black
threatens Knight D6 and you could lose
your knight on C5 in the blink of an eye
yeah Knight B6 is also a threat King B4
Rook B5 ideas
Knight B6 you're gonna have to flicking
D4 but I agree that's very undesirable
your king is moving the wrong direction
this is so tough
12 seconds for Tim Moore you'd think
this is in the back for Napa but it most
certainly is not given the way this
match is gone no it absolutely isn't
this is very stressful if you're a nepo
fan right now
how do you create
progress against Black's Fortress like
maybe maybe
no I was gonna say Rook C2 and try to
keep the Knight defended anytime you
move the king
oh my goodness have you been instead
he's gone King D4 and how do you stop
the night from jumping to B5 and then
back to D6
yeah I I'm I don't know
okay I think Rook C2 now you have to
play oh my God but then I'd be fine
Knight C7
yeah and you're just going to you're I
mean you're hey you just plays G4 Knight
C7 what's upon
he's just gonna lose his a pawn
he's losing his a pawn and you could
draw that with two seconds your job up
can pre-move knight C7
this is so wild
this is just
so uncharacteristic by Nepal I mean he
had a lot of chances this game
and black is better I mean listen I know
he's winning A6 he's not even losing the
C point
wow that is so shocking you were right
but this is just
this is just incredible yeah and young
looks away he has nothing he has
absolutely no tricks Knight A6 is
completely forced zero the black king is
safer
than
I don't even know what's
safest thing I can think of but
there's no course there's no nothing
this is unbelievable
I mean just 12 seconds no problem
okay last trick but no that's not even a
trick just Knight takes A6
yep scene q6 and 96 okay this is what
nepo's going for he will
on what a circumspect move there by
Timur just stopped the knight from
jumping into E6 and winning the Jeep on
apple he uh
just says more pawns than white now
that's it if he wasn't in a situation or
a draw wins in the match rajaba would
decline a draw here maybe even with the
amount of time he has
like try that on for size
I mean yeah I suppose you I mean you
could play for a flag right like you you
could really because your your chances
of
going home
oh my goodness yeah actually seriously
Rook H7 hey obviously EPO still has a
chance here I mean when your opponent
has four seconds a mouse slip blunder
one sick
oh my God this is this is actually
extremely stressful
Rook H7 yeah Rook H7 wait what oh boy
he's one upon back there's one
there goes one
but it's still a dead draw Levy because
this Pawn on G5 is holding enough of
white spawns he's giving up a second
bone too because he wants rookie three
yep King yep that makes sense three
seconds 84 and 94. one second oh who's
on time oh
and he blundered a second Pawn oh Timur
is getting nervous here he still should
be able to draw this oh my goodness this
isn't Rook D6 or something I mean
control seven yeah Rook C7 and 94 Rook
D6 your move
throw G6 I don't know go somewhere rugby
B6 something F7 back though
yeah that's that's smart oh he's gonna
go Rook Beast okay
he wants Knight D5
and he's gonna play it
and where is black skin going to go 94
okay
E3
now Neville has 55 seconds
yeah where are you running here like
what is what is the way forward I think
you zigzag your way to the queen side
politely asked black how he plans to
defend the G5 Pawn maybe he doesn't
maybe he doesn't defend it he just tries
to okay that's how he's gonna defend it
oh
wait what does Splat do what's the move
he's got one second oh my goodness oh he
wins the bottom H3
oh that's how he's gonna defend it by
not defending it
still this is so hard to defend Knight
takes G5 and whites I can torture that
position for a long time yeah you don't
even you don't even have to take yeah
Knight F7 Knight G5 is good I mean three
seconds remember
black can give away the night for the
white spawn and that's a pretty easy one
to draw now I would have played Knight
F6 there
yeah this is the rook and Knight versus
Rook is just very simple draw actually
gotta interrupt you nihal sarin has won
his game has drawn his game and he is
going to Canada
that's just incredible oh my God
yeah this is so stressful G5 you gotta
go G5 yep King f8 I would have gone okay
Knight G4 oh yep king of fortnite F2
hello
hello I think Tim Moore is going to
Canada I think we're going home night
intermezzo
oh my gosh
the old not over
oh
rookie for a knight D6 or BH check only
move but then King James
no Rook takes C4 is a drop C4 rookie
four rookie four that's it rookie four
and he's going to Canada not yet
rookie four was ending the game but I
guess Timur wants to sack the knife for
the Pawn King G6 no I don't like what
he's doing he's gonna have to give away
the Knight and he's gonna have to do it
right now oh he doesn't okay that's it
here we go 50. remaining gentlemen
yeah the only way that Seymour loses
this game is by getting mated losing on
time or hanging his Rook all of which
seem completely improbable
improbable but not impossible Levy he
missed Rook takes Knight which was an
immediate draw now he's gonna have to be
tortured
he's gonna have to pray to the internet
Gods yeah just go far away
go far away to avoid any Knight forks
and just walk your King around the board
and hope that you don't lose on time
yeah now we should clarify that rook and
Bishop versus Rook is a it's like a
different type of end game
here you don't even have to know any
technique all you have to know is don't
miss a fork because even if the king is
pushed to the back rank
the side of the Knight has zero winning
chance all
you know the only reason you lose this
is like you
fall asleep and now Timor has 10 seconds
on it this should be a pretty standard
draw
oh yeah
that's not gonna and also I've seen
people miss a discovered check in these
types
yes yes it is certainly possible
and uh yeah I mean nepo is within his
right 100 to play on a lot of people
might might sit there and go oh why is
he not taking the trouble because this
is it
I mean this is the game he's got he has
to win and
I think it would be disrespectful if he
didn't play on yep
like of course he's playing on You Know
Anything Could Happen you guys everybody
has to realize that eight seconds on the
clock we've seen much crazier things
happen
and Rook G5 it's crazy how close you are
to getting forked at any moment but this
is uh there are no Forks there are no
mates
there's no nothing we're 125 moves in I
think we are
27 Moves In
but more only needs about 22 more moves
and he's been nepo hasn't even gotten
him onto the side of the board
nope and he had him on the side of the
board to start it doesn't matter because
the king the rook and the Knight never
have peace they never just get to walk
up to the enemy King and deliver a mate
the Black Road constantly gets in the
way you meddling kids you know in your
Scooby-Doo and uh and that the black
Rook just continues to ask questions and
and this might be our longest game this
might be our Knight F3 by the way was a
fork but white would have lost the Rook
so that's that doesn't work
oh
but it doesn't matter that's the see
King C3 Rook H3 so teamwork and rest
peacefully here doesn't matter where the
king is as you said
yeah this is uh this is incredible I did
not expect these matches I did not
expect but either of these matches to
end in three games and I did not expect
either of these results which is
just unbelievable
just absolutely incredible I mean
you can take it you can take the Knight
that's it that's yep and apple offering
a draw
ing we're just going to Canada
see more of a job of
punches his ticket the final player to
qualify for the round of eight in the
chess.com Global Championship we will
see you in Toronto hopefully that
there's a whole thing about visas but uh
you know uh whether we get him there or
not he has made
is Mark he has won his group he has
taken down the top seed and he smiles
finally allows himself a discharge of
what must be some incredibly intense
emotions but let's not forget nihal
sarna is the second Hero of the Day both
players advancing to Canada on the heels
of a ridiculously convincing Victory two
wins in a row to start the match Levy it
will take me some time to process what
we just saw here today
yep what an absolutely amazing uh set of
matches truly uh we came into today with
three players and two of them up on your
screen right now who have just played in
the most recent candidates they finished
first and third respectively I mean they
were amazing in the classical portion
earlier this year they were very clearly
the top two seeds in the group and
um well I mean what what more to say you
expected a barn burner of a match but
did we expect such a dominant display
from one side
maybe not you know maybe not and Timur
is showing the world that if he's going
to beat yanyupomnishi who before the
entire event I chose as the winner
well
he's saying nope that's out the window
now uh I'm the captain and you better
look at me you better respect me you
better respect what I bring to the table
the waiver job of is playing the way we
have seen several players throughout
these early rounds uh build up that
momentum Dania I really feel like we are
we are witnessing kind of uh story arcs
in many ways
I think you really called it at the
start we're missing these quote-unquote
low rated players who are pushing all
that to the side you know and showing
that they don't care who they're playing
against they believe in the chess that
they play well it's more rajaba most
certainly did and our brave move of the
day uh Levy I chose this full disclosure
without your consultation but I don't
think you'll have a problem with this
because this is what started the fire
this is what led the genie out of the
box it was game one done a very
unfortunate opening experiment it's
punishes it in style in this position it
appears that white has great control
over the center nothing's gonna happen
right well how how wrong would you be if
you thought that you'd be forgiven
because B7 B5 comes out of the blue
forcing the C Pawn out of the picture
and D5 to open up the e-file comes next
and after the e-file opens the pressure
on the ninth by the Bishops by the Queen
by The Rook was insurmountable Levy and
our job of finished it off in style this
wasn't just a brave move of the day
these were the brave moves of the day
and he was making moves of the day all
match long yeah he really was that move
B5 is amazing they say that the punches
that hurt the most are the ones that you
don't see coming it looked like white
had some stability there but boom B7 B5
on the board D7 D5 the one two combo
from rajabov and I mean he's just
carried that momentum throughout the
match really it it got started went got
off to a bad start for nepo and it never
really got better
it never did it only gone got worse one
could Our Guest even more wins an equal
end game in the second game to push nepo
against the wall it was incredible and
now the racket the round of eight is
fully set we know who's going to Canada
we know who's going to be booking their
flights this week and it ain't gonna be
who we thought it was Levy both of these
results are crazy and we are the stage
is set for an incredible final at
Toronto as we look at the completed
group E bracket and it is Timur ajabov
who outlasts his opposition incredible
uh yeah absolutely incredible Timor has
risen up a level he is not just the
solid reliable with white and with black
super Grand Master that we have all come
to expect uh in fact you may remember
prior to the candidates he was literally
given I believe the second or the lowest
percentage chance of winning and he said
I'm gonna show you all what's up and he
got third place I'm not saying he was
given that the low of a chance here in
the chess.com Global Championship but
he's going up against Yani pomnishu who
is the favorite in this group and he
said nope doesn't matter three games the
minimum amount of time I need to win he
played an amazing set of games today uh
and he is the rightful winner of his
group and he is the rightful qualifier
uh to the final eight in Toronto
he is indeed and our second rightful
qualifier is nihal star and let's take a
look at their matched score it's uncanny
how similar these two matches were in
terms of their Arc disaster strikes in
game one or ding now unlike nepo it
seemed he was composed in game two it
seemed okay he's gonna create some
Chances with the black pieces but it was
not meant to be knee-haul with ice water
in his veins in his veins however you
want to say it Knight F4 and Knight
takes H5 and did all of ding's hopes to
make it to Canada the Halls aren't he
didn't just beat dingley Wren let's not
forget Levy he defeated Ralph mametov in
the previous round in incredible fashion
oh and by the way in between
yeah he beat some guy named Vladimir
kramnik this is one of the most amazing
runs of all time I I think that's not an
exaggeration yeah when we started this
event with the hundreds of qualifying
players and then the round of 64-32 and
16 and now down to eight we looked at
which of the young Stars would make it
to this live final uh we had Eric icy
right we had a couple of other young
talented players ranik sedwani was in
and ultimately none of them made it
except for nihal sarin and to get there
he had to take out one of the best chess
players in Azerbaijan Olympic I think
board four for them he had to take out
Vladimir kramnik who is arguably a top
five player of all time literally that's
not an exaggeration look of the career
of Vladimir kramnik and then he beats
ding Loren who is playing for the world
championship who is the second highest
rated chess player in the world and I
believe the only one currently above
2800 not named Magnus Carlson and he
beat him in three games
I mean what more do you want this is
literally ridiculous this is the best
storyline of this event how do you not
favor nihal Sarah now in Toronto I don't
know you have a legitimate case that he
could be a one or two favorite
you really could I mean he's such a
dangerous rapid player he always comes
arms armed it seems with the right types
of openings he feels so comfortable in
certain types of positions and when he
gets those positions the scariest thing
as I said before is that he doesn't care
who sits across from him historically a
lot of younger players they change the
way they're playing because I'm playing
this guy I'm playing that guy not
anymore the stronger players they're
gonna have to come Bluff free because
players like Nielsen are coming to get
them and he's gonna be coming to get
them in Toronto and before he's going to
be doing that he will be joining us for
an interview and I simply cannot wait
for that but we're gonna have to wait
for that
and uh we're gonna ask me Hall all about
his experiences in the match but we
wanted to remind you before we set nehal
up that the chess.com Global
Championship is brought to you by brave
brave means private browsing and so much
more by default Brave blocks ads and
trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com chess well knee-hal is about
to Brave the uh commentary Studio he
will be joining us for interview do not
go anywhere you're watching the
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave and we will have one of the top
eight Toronto finalists nihal sarin in
the studio on the other side of this
short break
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave we are
joined by the Gladiator Grandmaster
nihal sarin fresh off a rushing defeat
of dingley Wren to move on to the final
eight in Toronto nihal thank you for
joining us and a hearty congratulations
can you start by talking us through your
emotions right now and what you felt
right after you secured the draw in the
third game
uh thank you very much uh I did not
expect this at all I just I was just
hoping to put up a good fight and see
what happens then
the first game I think I managed to play
really well and uh that gave me some
confidence and
uh and the second game I swindled him
somehow then it was really
and also in the third game I got a good
question out of the opening so it was
much smoother than I could like ever
imagine
how you
you're one of uh the few young players
who
is in a really funny spot because
correct me if I'm wrong you've never
played a chess game against dingley Ren
until today is that accurate
oh can can nehal not hear me anymore
uh sorry I I heard something else no I
wrote
uh nihal can you hear me now this is our
producer yes I can yeah
okay uh yeah sorry I I asked you like
you're in a very unique position one of
our scorecards today showed you had no
head-to-head games against dingly red uh
that's obviously true for over the board
but even online we couldn't find any
games have you literally never played
dingley Ren before what is that like I
mean how do you like how do you even
prepare for that
all right
I just have never played in actually
wow so how does it go for Preparation
you just I mean you just look at his
lines his Tendencies and you just said
okay well I have nothing
yeah I hardly prepared actually uh I was
playing in
I played in Spanish league and European
Club cup so
it was already quite quite that after
those two tournaments and
also did quite a bit of work for the
tournament so I just uh for the match I
just prepared for like barely one two
hours
my legs
I adopted that strategy unfortunately I
don't think I'd have the same results a
D Hall in the round before you defeated
some guy named Vladimir kramnik pretty
weak player just kidding of course does
it does it mean something special for
you to beat someone like kramnik and did
you train with kramnik at all when he
went over to India what is it like to
defeat someone like that in a match
uh that was just it was just a great
feeling and
it's just a great honor for me to play a
match against
electronic Ding and so many strong
players in this tournament
no I I was not part of the
team that kramnik trained in India
so never got to work yeah
yeah that's yeah because kramek I know
there was some delegation of young
players uh who were trained by kramnik
back in the day that is true now my
question is you're always top five on
chess.com in Blitz and bullet but you're
also Rising rapidly In classical you are
not yet 2700 but I'm sure that we can
expect that from you in in some months
it's really just we're sorry we're sort
of just like yeah it's gonna happen no
no problem so I out of curiosity which
of the two what is the balance like does
rapid and does Blitzen bullet prepare
you better for this kind of online Rapid
or is it the classical and the
preparation and just being confident in
your openings because we see you
frequently have like 15 minutes on the
clock after 10 15 moves so which of the
two do you think helps more or does
everything help
now I think it's more like everything
helps the the preparation the opening
preparation part comes from Mostly
classical chess and
so you get to prepare good openings and
and definitely the online bits and
bullet practice helps especially in time
travel where it's it can be really tough
if you are
not just not used to the interface and
all that so I think it's a mixture of
both
final question for me this is a featured
chat question uh someone in the chat was
wondering if King G7 in game one against
thing you were playing very quickly in
the opening uh is it okay for you to
reveal whether King G7 was still part of
your preparation and if so when did your
prep end in that game
well yeah
I knew Kim jisan I think I remembered it
correctly and King jisan I think it
ended after like 92 I go Bishop D6 and
it's just a solid position
there's like engineers
yeah I don't know what's the point of
King j7 but okay
that's just what it says so you you just
played in yeah
last question just overall before we
before we let you go uh you have now
made it to the round of eight I don't
know if you know who your next opponent
is uh but it's it seems like it's live
on aronian so you I believe you have
played him I don't know what your extent
of experience is playing against Levon
how many times you've played against
each other what do you expect what can
we expect from you uh in uh in a few
weeks as we play our final eight
[Music]
um
it's just I'll just try to play good
chess and
I'm just very happy to make it
make it to a topic I don't think I've
played Lavan actually again I think
probably played some like friendly Blitz
or bug outside
oh wow that's amazing
with great anticipation Hall as you play
the top eight in Toronto see you in
Canada thank you so much for joining us
for the interview congratulations once
again congratulations thank you thank
you
okay
That's All She Wrote the final a
is going to Toronto and that big word
Champion it's gonna be decided in just a
couple of weeks Levy what a ride it's
been
it's been an array of just an amazing
ride
um and I think the busiest people for
the next few weeks are not even going to
be the players that is going to be the
Visa processing centers of their
respective cities and countries uh as
getting uh approval to actually travel
at the moment is kind of up in the air
the players will be busy preparing for
their matchups Visa processing centers
will be busy refusing visas on
completely empty grounds and uh it's
going to be a fun time for everybody
involved listen Daniel when we when we
started that bracket preview that feels
like it was literally ages ago ages ago
no and here we are and then there were
eight seven players actually no six
players of the eight in our
quarterfinals you saw in the last
candidates tournament one of these
players you have seen dominate in our
rapid events for months and the other
one nihal sarin the underdog the
teenager the youngest of the field by
something like 10 years I think the
closest person to him is maybe Duda in
age just incredible I mean what more can
you say this is what we wanted we got
one out of eight this time maybe in the
second edition of this event half the
field will be you know young young
teenage prodigies but this is just
Sublime I'm so excited no it's it's been
an amazing run it's been such a
privilege to have courtside seats uh as
we watch this field get thinner and
thinner we started with 128 players it
was like there's gonna be so many
hatches we're never going to get to
Toronto and as you said Levy here we are
you know the Visa processing centers are
indeed very busy the finals will be
coming your way at the start of November
and the atmosphere the tension is going
to be Amplified by the fact that it will
be taking place in person with
everyone's favorite players involves and
I'm just so so pumped to see the likes
of hikarnakamura and of course nihal
sarin and testing that 200 000 first
price it'll be awesome you will not want
to miss it and mark your calendar as
well
on that note ladies and gentlemen the
online portion of the chess.com Global
Championship has concluded the final
eight will be coming your way from
Toronto at the start of November
International Master Levy Rosman great
pleasure to commentate with you all
throughout the last couple of months
this has been such an amazing ride made
all the better by who I get to
commentate with I'll throw back to you
for uh your final Reflections before
before we wrap it up no this is listen
this is everything this is everything
we've wanted high stakes chess with the
best players in the world with emotions
being displayed live on camera to a an
audience that awaits not just great
brilliancies but also tragic blunders
and everything in between that is
basically it for the portion of the
event that we will stream from our homes
the next time you see us we will be
sitting live in a studio I'll still be
wearing colorful shirts I don't know if
Dania is going to be wearing a t-shirt
but we'll probably get him into
something a little bit more formal
yeah they'll try I don't know if they're
gonna succeed but this is it eight
players remain 200 000 for first this is
the highest single individual first
place prize of any event in 2022 we will
see you all in a few weeks in Toronto
and that's it Dania this has been great
and I think we're out we're signing off
in a wild ride we are indeed we'd like
to thank everybody in the chat on Twitch
and on YouTube for supporting your
favorite player the energy has been
phenomenal all throughout the seat you
see this wouldn't be possible without
the chat our sponsor Brave be joining us
all the way through to Toronto and of
course our incredibly hardworking
best.com team for their amazing work and
in particular our producers Allah and
our producer today big for their uh just
tireless efforts to make these
broadcasts as Flawless as smooth as they
are and make our jobs as easy as they
are so thank you everybody and for now
on a national Master Levy Rosman
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski getting you
goodbye from the online portion of the
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave we will see you at the start of
November in Toronto for the final eight
goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]